oh good
okay it's on uh three o'clock like to um
welcome everybody to the infrastructure
and services committee 13th September
2022. uh before we start the meeting
there's a marker respect for the passing
of her majesty the queen Queen We Will
first uh receive a karakia
from Evelyn
followed by a minute's silence thank you
everyone
is
[Music]
[Music]
foreign
[Music]
um
foreign
[Music]
foreign
foreign
thank you
we have no Zoom attendees today
apologies we have councilor Abbott Ms
pania coot and his worship
councilor amundson thank you for that
foreign
that moves on now to the public forum
um there were four speakers
unfortunately due to travel disruptions
uh Mr herself
um we'll be speaking at the next
infrastructure meeting so that takes us
now
to Tracy Peters um I'd like to welcome
you
to Tracy Peters here
Tracy will be speaking about the
footpath management policy uh Tracy you
have 10 minutes so
um what you can do is you can speak for
five and have five minutes of questions
or just use the whole 10 speaking it's
it's up to you okay thanks I actually
had a bit of a speech organized but then
I looked at all you guys sitting here
you look like you've got quite healthy
legs is that a good guess
how many of you have tried getting
around invercargill streets with a
walker
or a side stack or in a wheelchair
so I've got a bit of a challenge for you
see how much courage you guys have
who here has prepared to come out with
me as an observer for a couple of hours
to wander around invercargill streets
and see what the actual difficulties are
I can describe them to you but I think
it's actually better if you see them as
an observer or experience them
so who here has the courage to come out
with me and observe the realities of
getting round and the Cargill streets
excellent
so we can organize that because honestly
me getting here today
was an absolute Mission I had to go so
far out of my I couldn't take a straight
route to get here it's just physically
not possible apparently because of the
build
partly but mostly because the
transitions at traffic lights to
transfer from a footpath to a road you
just can't do it not without flipping a
wheelchair and personally that's just
not on my sort of timeline so if any of
you have the courage to come have a look
that'll be really good because then you
can actually see
what the issue is because I have spoken
to Russell Pearson
and on occasion and they think all about
bus stops and things and they promised
me that things will change
and they're doing their best but
nothing's changing like for instance I
would try to catch the bus from Clifton
to come into town but I can't
because the council redid the footpath
did a beautiful job but they put a piece
of grass between the curb and the
footpath
you can't get a wheelchair over it
because it's mud so I can't get on and
off the bus
so it's things like that I want you to
actually see not just to hear about it
but to actually see it
and as for um things like uh Curbside
Cafe isn't it I think they have a lot of
potential and they could actually be
really really good
but there's a few things to consider if
somebody is sight impaired where are you
going to put that seat in how are they
actually going to get down the footpath
without ending up in the road are they
going to use the side of the building or
are you going to put the cafe set in
there
so it's things like that I'd really like
you to come out and actually see it
firsthand so you can see what the
challenges are
because the city's got so much potential
but I'd just like to see it done in a
way that you don't have to redo it later
so is anybody any question right
um okay I'm going to open up two
questions
uh Council Lewis I think councilman
Scott
major one one one major problem like one
of the major problems one major problem
is getting out of vehicles and then
trying to trans
formers in the first traffic or perhaps
up to the boulder Series where yeah it's
really really bad a few uh for instance
on D Street outside
um spark or the Radiology there
you pull in and if your wheelchair's in
the back you're lifting the back of the
vehicle open physically into traffic not
only that but the car parts actually
physically not wide enough so if you do
get the wheelchair out of the back of
the vehicle they've then gotta try and
get it down to the door and if you have
another vehicle next to you you
physically can't do it because for a
wheelchair user the door has to open to
its widest
seating if you all think for a second
when you open your car door
do you open it let it go and then get in
or do you have one hand on your door and
then get into the car
my thought would be most of you will
have one hand on your door as you're
getting in
because you haven't opened it completely
if you'll say on I think it's dear on
the street just out there or kelvin
Street actually there's a wheelchair
park down by Woodbridge
there's a bit of a problem you'll get
out but there's no way you're going to
get up on the curve unless you were
physically in the traffic and go all the
way down to the museum and then get up
it's not safe for the driver it's not
safe for traffic
and it's certainly not safe with
wheelchair
so Mobility parking has to be thought
out a lot more carefully when Mobility
parking first came along
people like me were passengers and
somebody would help us out of the
vehicle and we'd go well I drive
I go out and I do things is that I can't
get up on curb so I have to really think
about it and I'm using a driving service
at the moment we pulled up outside h j
Smith's
I was on the road I couldn't get up onto
the curb so my driver actually stood out
on the road so I could go down to the
traffic lights to get up onto the curve
because there's no other way that I can
definitely
and
if you are a rear load for a wheelchair
vehicle you need seven meters minimum
absolutely seven meters you measure the
length of the vehicle you measured the
open door and you measure where you've
physically got a situated wheelchair to
load it
if you are side entry
you need at least three meters the width
of the vehicle the ramp
and getting it in
our Mobility parking is not fit for
purpose it's too narrow and it's too
short and it's not safe I think there
may be similar situations in South
invercargill but one of the problems
I've noticed there frequently uh
questions please uh the question being
that where people are parking who aren't
entitled to park how do you cope with
that it's an ongoing issue
um it's I try to deal with an extreme
care because some people can take
offense
often I will actually go up and say hey
look my driver's about to pull up would
you guys be okay if you just move for a
couple of months so I can get in and out
and they'll do that if
I see them parking and unloading
but it is a major issue and it happens
all over town where somebody else will
park there and you just you just can't
use a car park it's just not possible
we're thinking okay councilor skill now
through YouTube thank you for your
presentation which is somewhat
concerning to be fair
I just wonder the question being from a
consultation process
are we as a council interacting with the
disability groups when with the likes of
the CBD the langlands hotel and all the
new developments are we proactively
because I know Russell has a real
concern a real opinion for contempting
with the consultation so are we doing
enough from a console
from a consultation process if we're not
um we need to fix it clearly but I'll be
Keen to hear from Russell also if that's
allowable just his response
unfortunately okay I'll go back to to if
you would not
um so back to that consultation process
there is there isn't not enough
happening
when you do make a decision you haven't
really taken into consideration the
realities which is why I invite you to
actually come out and see it
because I think your staff are doing the
best they can but I have a suspicion
that at times something's been lost in
translation for instance when you let
out a contract to a contract you might
be saying we want you to do this
that you're speaking to the supervisors
the extra crew that are doing the work
and I've had this conversation with some
of the contractors that are doing isk
Street
I went down there on the initial stages
and they had made a wooden ramp with a
skip like that I couldn't use it so I
come came up to the council and I had to
talk to somebody the lady downstairs was
great she took my details and said oh
we'll talk about this and get back to
you in a few months
and I thought oh great and I'll be back
down there and the contract was there
and he came out to me and he says oh I
made a ramp and I was just wondering
what do you think of it and I said too
high
he had and I had a five minute
conversation the next day problem solved
he just got some plywood and shaved it
on down and and did it and those ramps
that they are now using an East Street
much better
so just to drill down further through
your chair um with the CBD development
and the langlands have you still got
some concerns around both those
developments I do have some serious
concerns about those developments you're
making rain Gardens
um
and they're nice but are you going to
put a barrier around them
because if a wheelchair gets too close
or a toddler gets too close they're
going to go into them
thank you okay thank you councilor Scott
I'm gonna go we're just about at time
our last one is counselors open
consultation I know that the DPA
isn't um active and invercargill at the
moment is there a group that we are
missing that you can tell us about to
consult more with ccs
um I'm with CTS I'm one of the Lac there
but call them so I'll be happy to have a
talk to you have a have a discussion but
you really do need to consult with the
community and the CCS will be more than
happy to come and have a chat
and to sit down with you guys at the
table and decide and figure out between
us all
what's realistic what can you
realistically do and what our needs are
and come together in the middle so CCs
is taking the roles that disabled
persons assembly would have taken some
years ago if DPA was still functional
that'd be great unfortunately we cannot
get them to
to open up again down here but we do
have ccs and CCs is actually a really
fabulous organization and there are lots
of people who consult through CCS they
have a wide membership basis
thank you thank you that is now 10
minutes Tracy thank you very much
I'm Mary O'Brien I'm the excess
coordinator from CCS disability
right yeah the next Seminole you're the
next segment it's a minute well done
yeah sorry
no carry on so
sorry no no it's all good sorry no I
just sorry I did
I did yeah
[Music]
it doesn't matter
oysters
um okay
um I'm the excess coordinate it Sissy's
disability action and first of all I
just want to
um
Tracy's story are common stories right
across there we are right where way so
and can can we just bring the microphone
over here
um just before I move on
the stories that Tracy tells are common
across New Zealand common across the
world and it's not just an inconvenience
26 of the Southern population have got a
disability we've got an aging population
things are going to become more and more
challenging where disability
organization and we speak from that
point of view but the really important
thing is that if you've got things right
for disabled people you've got things
right for the rest of the population and
as people get older and we've got young
people things are going to become much
more difficult so that's that key thing
it's like you've got a sentinel
population and the other thing about
disabled population we're now getting
quite a good research and evidence space
about the consequences of that
so a lot of disabled people across New
Zealand have trouble going to the doctor
because they simply can't get there
um because kids can't get to school
often they have a poor education so that
carries on right through their life they
don't give a good tertiary education
they don't get good work
their well-being suffers so you know
just going back to yeah
um so this one here we really support
this whole idea of Cafe licensing and we
totally agree with what you say about
streets creating the vibrancy of the
city they do but you've got to make sure
everybody can use them every
um
Street or every intervention in the
world where you increase
pedestrianization you immediately get
more people they spend more money people
feel safer it just goes on and on their
endless benefits so getting back to the
cafe licensing that image up there on
the right that's from ncta pedestrian
guidance and if you look at the right
there there's a clear pathway along the
building
that's also what's recommended
um by the nzta and road traffic standard
14 which is around provision for blind
people with who are blind and low vision
so if you have that clear walkway right
along
people who have Vision impairments and
use stick can go up and down everybody
else can go up and down you've got a
through route in the middle for people
who want to scoot along and walk quickly
and then on the left hand side there
this is place for tables and you can see
on that image you've got some planter
boxes but you can also see there are
transitions in the paving
so that signals to people that there are
differences
so that's what we recommend for your um
for the cafe licensing thing
so that's the just the safe continuous
um
route of travel
um
the thing safety is a key reason why
people choose to use the footpaths now
that's not just people with mobility
issues it's people who might want to
catch the bus if the footpath's safe and
good then they can move along it quickly
they'll catch the bus to work all of
those things out and it's not just one
small
um
group of people
I might just move down to the last slide
now please
so Tracy's spoken about Consulting with
the disabled community and we're really
happy to support you to do that
we do a lot of consultation around that
anything that when you were working with
people who have got disability advice
Advantage you really need to think pose
missing out and that's what you need to
ask
so when you're thinking now about the
footpaths
where are people going and why why why
you know and then that next thing is why
where aren't people going and why can't
they go
Tracy mentioned Mobility parks
we did some research
um
quite a few years ago and we thought
there were about 30 of Mobility Parks
being misused
um a colleague of mine who does a lot of
research into transport injury thinks
it's close closer to 50 percent
most of the people who uh pack this say
oh
it was only there five minutes but if
you go to town and you're in your van or
your car and there is a limited number
of parks and it's parked
most people just go home again because
they've lost that opportunity
so that that really is a big deal
um
so what we're saying about this process
is that we recommend that you conduct
some Street accessibility Audits and
that specialist audits
um it's and then the other thing is use
that to prioritize the improvements so
we've seen
talk to the disabled Community find out
who can and can't go where
and then use those findings because you
can't fix everything overnight but you
need to fix the areas that are the most
important that are causing the most
abstractions and my hazards and um yeah
so I'm just thinking about some other
things that um
Tracy said
disabled people overall make
first of all they probably don't go if
it's inaccessible otherwise they'll make
less trabs or then if they can't make
the trip they'll make longer a more
difficult trips so that's the kind of
thing that we um
pick to deal with the other things to
think about New Zealand standards are
not up to date we don't have best
practice transport engineering and those
sorts of things in there so that's why
when you get the information with the
community you do need to underpin that
with expert access advice
yeah
um
and this is why after years and years
and years of that because see that
finally there is disability legislation
before Parliament
but at this stage we think it's not
going to be effective
anything else I should have said Tracer
yeah so um that's all for me okay right
we're at seven minutes so we got three
minutes for some short sharp questions
so Evelyn
number and range of Mobility
I don't know the right weirdest vehicles
but Mobility devices has that affected
some of
the kind of use that we're now seeing
where
um disability spaces are not big enough
or wide enough for
um
I I totally see why you're saying about
outside
um
spark those sorts of places but is it
because the nature of the of the so
we're not keeping up with the technology
is that what you're saying that's right
our standards aren't keeping up with the
changes so people now have um bigger
heavier wheelchairs so then people need
a bigger vehicle particularly electric
chairs where people might need to use a
van
so then you might get into the park but
you can't get out of it
especially rear loading bands yeah and
that's a really good
sort of symbol yeah that's definitely
right and and further to that
um
most people not everybody but most
people who use Mobility devices are
passengers rather than drivers but do we
have quite a number of drivers now where
the access points are not suitable
because it's a different issue isn't it
and it's people are making assumptions
that everybody is going to be a
passenger and they're going to be able
to get out on the footpath and what what
what we're hearing today I believe is
that there is not necessarily as common
as it used to be I think oh it's more
you know
example you're saying about people like
I have a friend who bungee jumps does
the luge but there are Parts in Dunedin
where he can't get out of his car
when you survive it yeah so what we've
got to think about then is
not
block or crossing by Crossing you've got
to look at a certain area mark it off
audit it make sure that you're fitting
up with with Universal Design for best
practice transport engineering and those
sorts so you want to make some
accessible routes which means people can
have an unreactive Journey yeah so
people can get out on the driver's side
as well as on the passenger side yeah as
well as from the the rear
so in essence it means that we're asking
the council to exceed the current
standards which aren't good enough but
that doesn't actually mean a lot more
money it just means
asking and finding out what how they
should be and then doing you know often
it's just
making it leaving a bit more room those
sorts of things thank you for the
clarification thank you thanks Evelyn
right our last we've got time for Leslie
thank you Mr chair Mary can either you
or Tracy quickly just point to one or
two parks in invercargill that have got
it right that are good examples for us
to look at please pass
Queen's Park Queens Park
um if you go in towards where round past
the animal park down towards the cafe
there
it's it's not bad because you can
straddle the middle
and
and it's often Mary have you got any
that you could add
I don't live in invercargill
um so I'd have to rely on Tracy but uh
I would say
to find one that's used that actually
meets this
what would be accessible for everybody
across the country would be a rare event
yeah okay right thank you Mary that's 10
minutes so thank you
thank you Tracy as well thank you for
the opportunity
sort of starting
right uh next we welcome Carolyn
now we just get the microphone just a
fraction closer
excellent how
I just want to clarify because it's just
checking my um notice of this meeting
today which came
about three weeks ago and it said the
first
um submission I was doing was
uncontrolled parking policy is that
correct
because you did talk about we've got you
we've got you down as footpath
management policy and but we also have
you submitting to the parking control by
law so you've got two submissions there
yeah and I've got one for myself correct
you've got one on behalf of the blind
citizens and one by yourself yeah
okay so which one am I doing first you
are doing the put path management policy
on behalf of the blind citizens New
Zealand thank you just wanted to clarify
that supposed to have the right one
first okay so
um blind people have always been
concerned about access through um
footpaths and making sure that we are
safe and that we can actually go places
and we have people that use white canes
we have people that use guide dogs
um people that use white canes it's
really important that they have
something that they can feel along that
they can actually maneuver along and use
as a guide and we have
um most people have been taught to
actually use shop fronts as the place to
orientate themselves with their white
canes and that's why we've advocated
that
um there shouldn't be any furniture or
any obstacles by walls of shops and that
however we understand that you know in
invercargill you don't want people
sitting out in the rain like today if
they're having a coffee outside you know
they want to be warm and um dry so we
actually acknowledge that and one of the
things that Tony and I noticed when we
went to Canada something over 20 years
ago in there was that all their cafes
and restaurants outside had fences
around them and they actually made the
professors really pretty and they
actually had um
even you could put your
advertisements on the fence so you could
put your menu put that on the fence and
that and so people could read that on
the fence and the fence would give a
blind person using a white cane a guide
to show them how they can get around
that cafe or restaurant safely without
starting to bang into chairs and tables
and people and goodness knows what I
mean the worst place for um trying to
maneuver is around by the library where
you have a couple of cafes there in the
summer time it's Bedlam blind people
just can't get around there because it's
too dangerous
um it's not necessarily the cafe people
that the staff that shook the tables and
chairs around it's actually the public
who use them and I just leave tables and
chairs all over the place if they had a
little fence area and one of the places
that do have had this and I've seen it
is um waxy show so if you go to waxy
first choice and they often had a little
fancy and they have a nice area where
they look quite lucky you've got a
little sort of area outside that they
have fenced in there is also some other
areas in town that have been produced
that have a out an Alco
that's out on the street so it gets on a
nice sunny day people could use that for
cafes but it's really important that we
do have no obstacles running around the
shop fronts or if they're fenced in
they'll be safe but we don't want tables
and chairs
goodness knows pot plants already and
people all Milling around and sitting
around in blind people come running it
you know walking into them who's going
to be dangerous blind people but not
only that the other people that use that
Cafe could get knocked over as well or a
child so I think you need to think about
health and safety as well as access
these days the other thing about
um
footpaths as you talk about shed
footpaths and we've always been opposed
blind citizens New Zealand is always
opposed to that and we're blind people
speaking for ourselves so we know
exactly what that's like
um
you can have people on push bikes and
it's ironic that there's a shed footpath
outside blind low vision NZ building
it's always been there I don't know why
I of course shouldn't let that happen
um but anyway
people come up behind your back and and
they're um you know riding a bicycle you
can't hear them and there's a lot of
people with deaf blindness now more and
more people who are coming into blind
low vision who are elderly or blind
citizen elderly are deaf-blind it's
really incredible the number of people
at such an increase in that and people
who are blind and have other physical
disabilities like myself now
um so
shade footpaths is really quite
dangerous for us and this I remember
people used to have bells on their push
bikes I wish they had bells and then
they could ring their Bell just before
they came up to you and you wouldn't be
so frightened it also means that guide
dogs get frightened of vehicles that are
using shared footpaths because they're
trained to help you and they walk on a
straight line and if somebody comes up
especially
High School kits and they come up and
they come so close to you the guide dog
can get frightened and then it puts a
dog's work and then you know out and
then the poor blind person is um
actually
disadvantage it could be in a dangerous
situation so it's really important that
guide dogs concentrate on their work and
so we just ask that um shared footpaths
uh thought about and if if you do you
know putting a
a painted line down the middle isn't
going to help blind people if you're
going to do a [ __ ] [ __ ] up put a tactile
indicator line down the middle so people
with white canes feel that tactile and
know that they're on the correct side
and I don't know why that isn't already
done outside blind low vision building
because a lot of our blind citizens
members walk around the quiet you know
mobile and um
and there's nothing to indicate to the
blind person who's using a white cane
like fit West
um what side of the road what side of
the footpath is on so surely one of
those
um yellow
tactile indicators just down the middle
would be a quite a cheap way of fixing a
problem that does exist
I guess the other thing is we are very
pleased to see in the policy about
um reinforcing your bylaw with regards
to
cars on footpaths that is a big hassle I
understand it's a big um hassle around
um around by the rivers
um some of the streets those narrow
streets around by the rivers up north
invercargill a lot of cars have been put
apart on footpaths because there's
nowhere to park them on the road because
the road is so narrow
and so I know some members who live
around the areas saying it's very
difficult and they had to walk on the
road the guide dog is stuck in the
middle of the road narrow road car can
come with him by guide dog it's Brighton
and stops I'm concentrating and so the
member is quite dangerous as well
because I know that when I had a guide
dog you've had your guide dog on the
usually on the traffic side of the road
not always depends what side but if the
guide dogs on the traffic side of the
road they're quite vulnerable and we
certainly don't want to have
um guide dogs run over because of course
um they certainly cost a lot of money so
I think that other other major issues
that we want to point out around about
um
the things about
um Gardens you know like
blind people are always passengers and
so we're going to get off the out of the
car on the um
streets you know where the footpath is
and in places like Clyde Street and by
the library and that there's big boxes
with plants and trees and goodness knows
what and you get out and it's really
hard because you can't work out where to
go if you've got a walking frame or a
wheelchair or a guide dog or using your
white cane
you gotta it's really sometimes hard
because there's not enough room for you
to get round past the Garden or past the
tree or whatever before you could fall
in a fight fall in the tree I'm gonna
end up in the hospital and I'm gonna get
told off for falling in the tree
with broken bones so yeah that's just
the last plot that I wanted to make I'm
ready for questions okay look you've got
about 30 seconds left but because you're
speaking twice later on I think we can
sneak some questions in there so I'll
accept one question and that's from
Darren thanks Carol
um what about those venues where they
have a recessed area back from the the
natural edge of the footpath that that
they're able to utilize is there some
form of barrier
uh that would still be appropriate along
that
the recess area is all right at the back
but you probably need something at the
front you know and have a little gate
Gateway or an entrance I mean obviously
you're going to have to have an entrance
but you'd probably want something just
so that because people are on the
walking on the footpath the the
the part that goes around is sort of
going out out of the footpath so it's
around yeah it's no you probably need
just a little fence around the front of
it as well it's to keep the furniture
and the people sort of inside you know
just to make sure that they know their
spot and the people who walk know their
spot that's all thanks Carol right thank
you Carolyn
um we'll hear from you shortly
in fact
um uh we'll just get rid of these
minutes and you can actually stay there
I could stay there probably yep you can
stay there so uh next on the agenda is
minutes of the infrastructure Services
meeting held 2nd of August 2022 can have
someone move that they are true and
correct thank you councilor Scout
seconded
Ms cook I'll put that all those in favor
all right against that is carried Now we
move on to the hearings for the parking
control bylaw and uh first submitter is
Carolyn Weston
hi again this time I'll talk about I
don't have as much to say this time so
don't worry
um control parking and I've actually
been talking to some taxi drivers who
have mobility vans because I've been
having to use them myself and Tony can't
take me somewhere although I can use a
car but they were very concerned about
the car parts for Mobility
um
users
in invercargill
um they if they're driving a taxi van
they're using those car Parks probably
quite a lot and they're experiencing
firsthand the problems that
um taking a person out you know if you
go into one of those car parks that go
on an angle and then they had to open
the door at the back and then they let
the person down or out through a ramp
someone's got ramps and some have got
um hoists they let them down
and they're right on the on the middle
of the street so you know it's very
dangerous
um the other issue for them
is that if you're people in the car and
Tony and Tony said to me the other day
and tell me when we were apart this is
you don't you have to open your door
wider and I said I do but I'm waiting
for my wheelchair to come and then I
open my door wider but there isn't
enough room and I know another I know
Tracy has told you about that so I'm not
going to talk too much about it but I do
know that this very narrow Mobility car
parks at the airport because I haven't
been there for a long time but I do
remember even it was just a white cane
or a guide dog it was very diff and a
walking stick it was quite difficult
even to park there there was no room
on the sides of the car to either driver
or the passenger really struggled to
open your door wide so I just think that
it's really important
um also in your policy talked about
having two Mobility Parts in s Street
and two and Dawn Street I think that
might be sound alright for today but we
need to look at the future and a
strategic thinking governance body such
as the city council should be thinking
about not today but in 10 years time how
many people will be disabled and
invercargill in 10 years time and
visitors and you'd probably be better to
have three Mobility parts now get them
there now don't wait until it's too late
and people don't have enough
so
um the other issue about parking is of
course
the um
oh sorry it's going out of my head oh
yeah just to make sure that
that when people
um have mobility issues that they can
get from the road onto the
foot path without having too much of an
issue now and people in wheelchairs
need flat but people who are using a
white cane need something to indicate
the difference between the road and
and the footpath so it's really
difficult to make sure it's a
consultation with ccs is fine but you
also need to consult with blind citizens
South and branch and we do have a very
good relationship with Russell and
Nathan and Amelie
um and so it's really great and but we
haven't had a talk together for about a
year
so um I think consultation is good but
talk to blood talk to the disabled
people don't talk to the people who work
in the agencies they can tell you what's
happening at a at a level that they work
at like servicing and what it's like for
them to see what and observe but it's us
we experience firsthand what disability
is and just one little last point the
government
U.N convention on the rights of disabled
persons has um been monitored by the U.N
and
just a couple of weeks ago and there's
some good documentation just came out
about how the New Zealand government has
feared in that situation some things are
okay but there's a lot of work still to
be done in the area so I thought I'd let
you know that thank you okay right I'm
going to open up for questions for
Carolyn
Council clerk just just two questions
through each year one for Russell to
start with are you sitting behind me um
and esken and Don Street the uh we're
parking at the very time limit at all
isn't it it's just a former drop-off
type thing
so Carolina knobby Clark um just
wondered how you'd feel about having
more disability
um
parking in those two streets if they're
really only for drop off and pick up
they're not to sort of drop you off stay
there for a while and you go do a bit of
shopping and then come back but really
okay open the door and drop the person
and really move on to somewhere else
with his car parking
um
yeah well when we had the consultation
over a year ago with Russell about the
inner city
um upgrade and everything we talked
about Mobility parts and the disabled
people it was at the library Russell you
might remember and the um disabled
people were quite insistent about having
parking in that area but there was no
talk at that stage of just being a
drop-off area so I think that's
something that you do need to talk to
the disabled community of invercargill
we do really need another one of those
meetings I think just to discuss and let
people know what your intentions are I
mean maybe there must be some other
areas that people can park I know and my
sister only has one eye she's
um had the other eye removed and she
will never be able to walk um drive her
car and to um the car parking buildings
because she's got no 3D Vision so that's
an issue for her
um so she has to park on out on the
street so one of these things is
there'll be other people that have not
got through the
Vision so think about all the needs of
people and what I mean maybe there's
going to be part more parking and Tay
Street for example
um or Kelvin Street and D Street I don't
know but we need to discuss this further
to make sure that everybody's on the
same page because that's more important
isn't it
and that's and second question through
each year is the issue of um what's your
experience around covered car parking so
how do those visually impaired deal with
the uh
um h j car park that requires moving up
levels and the same in the in the cable
central block that we've refer to as the
more in the experience than that or is
there a preference to have a street side
um
hexes
um
blind people can't drive and so they
usually are going to go to a covered car
park they will go with a sighted person
so they depend on a side of person to
help us
um get around those areas because they
are quite dangerous they're very dark
and dingy and you know we're getting
quite a few more of those and
invercargill but most um blind people
that are live by themselves actually use
taxis or you'd use the bus so it's
probably not really an issue we've
discussed but maybe it'll come an issue
in the future I guess the main issue is
when you're walking along the footpath
and people come out of those covered car
parts and in their car and
you know there's no way of knowing
unless the drivers continually took
their horns before they come onto the
footpath which I know that my husband
does but a lot of drivers don't do that
so you don't always know and with these
electric cars coming into Vogue and
they're silent it could be quite
dangerous for blind people so it's an
issue that we're probably going to look
at at the future
okay okay
so or maybe if all the car Parks had a
wee bowel a big Bell
it was something some noise that when
the car comes out
um
that Bell would Wrangle the buzzer that
would indicate to a blind person that
there's a car coming across that part of
the footpath that would be helpful
she's raised the third issue for me if I
can just squeeze the question yep no no
we've got um an example of that sensor
Bell is the h j car park so that's as a
car comes out it generates an automatic
um noise but it's been my experience of
the people driving the cars just I think
they can zoom out over the footpath it
helps the person walking but it doesn't
necessarily help the if it's in the car
so yeah um
no they're supposed to be I thought that
when you come out of a driveway or a car
park you're supposed to stop before you
go across the footpath because you don't
know who's on the footpath and there
could be a child a little child or
something and you wouldn't see them so I
think that that maybe that needs to be
education on thank you okay right we now
have time
um so we have Carolyn speaking again so
Evelyn if we want to save the question
tell the next one
um it's more oh well it was about the
parking meters actually so it's probably
relevant to this one
um well Carolyn is speaking to the
parking control by law on behalf of the
blind citizens right now thank you so if
she's got another 10-minute Forum so
um chapter two Carolyn you are now
speaking on behalf of the blind citizens
New Zealand
and yeah
I'm confused now you have another 10
minutes this is a new this is your
second submission uh-huh yep the
previous one was your independent
submission yeah and now this is and this
is um
uh the parking controlled by law right
thank you so um there's not much to say
now but
um so I guess really importantly as I've
talked about blind people and disabled
people but I'll concentrate on blind
people parking
um is a really important
um for blind people
if it's as I said not parking on
footpaths and that's really good you're
not doing that but we are concerned that
do you have the resources to actually
monitor car parking on property and I
know that's in the bylaw but and and
you've got a good intention about that
but in reality can you actually do it
think about that
um parking I think these issues about
parking for
um blind people when there's things like
sandwich boards and that's where we want
them to be but there's also needs to be
an area that people know they're safe to
get out in and out of cars so there's
that relationship between sandwich
boards being by the gutter which we want
but also making sure that
um that they're not going to impede
people
who are blind or any other disabled
people actually who get in and out of
the passenger side of the car making
sure yeah so it's just another barrier
but yeah with what we've got to do is
try and reduce the barriers that's what
disabled people are doing throughout the
world is trying to reduce our barriers
to take away the disabling factors of
our impairments because we actually have
impairments we don't have disabilities
we actually have just impairments the
disability factor is what society's
created as a barrier for us so if you
take away all the barriers there won't
be disabled people we'll just be vision
impaired or blind or hearing impaired or
physically just impaired people and we
won't have disabled people at all that
would be
the the beauty of it all but I mean when
is it ever going to happen won't be my
lifetime anyway so
um so just looking at what is barriers
and then try and to eradicate them or
reduce them to an extent that they're
not going to be causing so much a
barrier so I guess the major issue is
thinking about when you put the car
parts and when you put I'm not quite
sure why someone wants to ask me a
question about
um parking measures I can't even see
where they are now I knew that parking
meters used to be
um if you went to the front of the car
you had to find a parking you could feel
either parking meter was and then people
put their money and not that I even knew
how but I knew that career but now I
have no idea where the parking meters
are
so
um so I don't worry about parking
because I don't have to look for them
I'm not a driver but
um my husband is complaining because he
doesn't know where the parking meters is
and he says I don't know where the
market I can't help him I can't see them
either so
um yeah so I'm not quite sure what
department can be the questions about
but we just want to make sure that
everyone's safe thank you okay right
we've got a good time seven minutes for
questions Evelyn
so through you Mr chair the reason I did
ask is because you made a comments about
your husband saying about the parking
meters
um so I guess this is about your
conversation
um
about if we remove the
um
if we move the barriers remove the
barriers to your access to spaces that
you no longer are disabled but you are
still impaired
um and that goes to
people particularly non-sighted people
needing somebody else to take them
places actually if it's a vehicle we we
shouldn't we shouldn't have to rely on
somebody taking us to places however if
you're in a vehicle if you're going a
distance that you can't walk or you
don't want to use public transport for
so what can we do or what are you asking
of the council to do or perhaps it's
your husband that needs to answer this
question that makes the parking for
people
accompanying people with
um some physical impairment or I think
if we're if we're lowering the barriers
what should we be doing in terms of the
parking because it is a parking issue if
the meters are not located properly or
you can't access to pay or things like
that what should we be doing and uh have
there is there a solution that you have
in mind apart from moving every single
one that's just been important
um I'll have to ask my husband about
that he I just need to explain that he's
just had recently had a cataract
operation and he's got another cataract
growing on his other eye but he's also
got some scarring tissue on the other
eye as well so he actually probably
can't quite see it as normal at this
stage until he gets his new glasses so
I'll let him I'll let him speak Tony you
want to answer Tony if you're going to
speak can you please can you bring the
microphone close to you please
not much thoughts gone into the
placement I mean you've got pack meters
one end of a block they've all packed
down the other end you've got to walk
all the way down
to the meter and you might be going to a
shop somewhere near where you pack so I
mean what do you do I don't bother going
to the meter I just duck into the shop
but I actually think
um
Ian I think it is and Russell should
make an appointment with the account
departs underneath and then have a look
at what they've done near when you pack
they've got so many perks to a meter and
when you get out of your car and walk to
the curb there's an arrow saying which
way to the meter
now I struck that problem in space
Street got out the car and it was one
there one near which one do I go to
probably went to the wrong one but I
think it'd be a good idea if you used to
go up to Dunedin have a look and get
some more meters and put them in the
correct places and have so many parks to
a meter
and and have painted arrows on them and
I've actually found one block around
town where there was no meter
and I don't think it's supposed to cross
the road to a meter hmm
um just one thing too about the parking
meters last Wednesday I was in town with
my alternative care support worker and
um she was struggling to work out how to
actually
um work the meter and I said oh don't
they have any instructions on the meter
and she said she didn't really know but
I you know she took quite a while and I
was sitting in the chair waiting for her
to sort out how she worked out a meter
and I said that'd be a pain she said
well I don't know if it's gone or not
I'm not sure if it worked or not so he
goes there might be some training
involved you might need to have some
workshops public workshops on how to
work those meters
right we've still got a couple of
minutes no no you most welcome sweet
Danny okay yep
I was going to say she took with the car
packs you've got parking signs like this
was the cab pack you got the parking
side here
so passenger can't open the passenger's
door and get out so you you can't pack
there or you've got to move and I think
those sides should be put between the
two packs
put them between the two packs I was got
a passenger they can open the door
without having to bang onto the pole
um further questions we've still got a
couple of minutes
no well that's thank you thank you very
much Tony and Caroline
right we have one further submitter for
the parking controlled by law and that
is Terry Gibson
Terry welcome
everybody Terry Gibson tonight oh just
bring the microphone all right yep good
sweet
what am I doing I'm sorry I'm not sure
oh no first time yeah sorry 10 minutes
uh you have so if you want some
questions questions asked say speak for
five or six and you get four minutes
worth of questions so or will you expect
for tea and then use the hollow well I'm
just one because I live down Q Road and
there's a lot of um all of a sudden I've
been there for over five years and they
decided to get someone to come down and
start putting tickets on everyone's cars
um these 19 minutes I've I'm there
living there and I pack my car out and
it was me that got the ticket so I did
write in and asked for it to be
got rid of which they were kind enough
to do but um residents most of those
houses down that road are owned by the
the hospital anyway so the very few
residents that are there I know that
there's going to be a new subdivision
going in there so there might be more
people that be using you know reusing
that road do we actually need those
signs there the 90 minutes
because I've been speaking to this
gentleman over here
Russell down at South City
and they said it was put in there quite
a long time ago
um
the nurses do use it because they've got
CTV cameras out the front I've been
speaking to some of the nurses and they
said safety reasons is why they want to
park out there
the only reason why that it started to
get quite congested at the time was due
to the back of the hospital doors being
closed so most people used to go through
the back end to get into the hospital
and so that's why it became quite
congested out on Q Road now the doors
are open we don't have the same problem
so do we really need those 90 minute
signs
can someone answer me
we can't give you answers on this this
is like a public forum you can speak we
can ask you questions uh this will come
out when we deliver
um do the deliberations on
on those uh so okay uh the suggestion is
too it's like how like in Dunedin places
like that if you live in an area where
there is an unlimited length of time is
that the people can actually get a it's
something to go in the car and so that's
what my suggestion was is that we just
get if you live there residential and
the other thing was was because I felt
that the um whoever was ticketing was
quite unfair because they just did a
select part of the street because a
friend lives down the other end her cars
were packed exactly the same length of
time as mine under 90 minutes
and she never got a ticket
so you know you got to be fair when you
are Distributing these things out yeah
all of a sudden there's not as many
nurses parking out there but one thing
that they did say because they've had
the car break-ins and the car Parks
especially sometimes when they go in if
they've come onto a shift that's earlier
than normal they want to come out and
feel safe when they're walking to their
cars so I usually get the nurses do come
out on these shows but they feel safer
coming out to the side where there is
they can be watched by CTV basically a
lot clearer and Mr Russell did say that
it's probably a hospital thing but still
our nurses work in our community and we
need to keep them safe no matter what
male or female
right okay so what we're going to do now
is we can open up for uh questions
um
do we have questions for Terry councilor
Lewis thank you Jerry you mentioned in
your submission that that a lot of the
time they officers owned by the hospital
are not occupied is that a common thing
yeah
the reason I ask is if you think
take away the 90-minute parking would
they not be packing there all day for
example and then you wouldn't get the
chance of any bags no because the um the
pop sorry can you repeat your question
thank you basically
can you speak into your microphone
because I can't hear you thank you I'm
trying to ask
a question in a way that would allow for
people to that were living in the houses
be the hospital employees or not of the
parking there all day and then if they
were packing all day
at the moment if there's 90 minute
parking the parks would come free every
so often no it's not because they
usually that residential there to go in
there are usually doctors that come over
for every now and then like they might
have come down from Hamilton for a
three-month stint and things like that
so those are the most of the ones are
but there's going to be new subdivision
put down our area so they might have
people that are visiting them and they
might be staying overnight it's just
that you know we're not sure when we're
going to get a ticket and like in five
years there's been nothing and that's
how long I've been living there and
people who've been like I'll ask my
neighbor next door Leslie Hyde she said
she's never I've never seen anyone come
down there either so it's someone's made
one person's made a complaint so that's
the reason why they started to go oh we
need to get these tickets handed out
then yeah thank you
cancel clock
yeah um just seems to me that you've um
you've got three three sets of people um
competing for the same car Parks
Hospital workers who prefer to use the
street as opposed to the car parks
around the back which they have night
can be pretty scary places
um visitors who might be in the hospital
for what they think is an ar2 and could
be there all day yep um in residents who
could be the hospital staff who are
living in that area as well in those
houses so I guess for us what's the
priority
these really
um like I mean I don't mind I live next
to the hospital and I come from Auckland
and you know trying to get car park
around Auckland hospital is dynamic you
know um
it's it's I think with with it if we
don't actually need them to be quite
honest I don't see the purpose of them
being there
um I can understand why like a lot of
people they walk across
um the nurses especially from there to
the emergency area or they work in front
of house so they're the ones that
generally um Park out our side that I've
seen because I see them all the time
I'm not worried about it but the
residential ones when you say about the
hospital staff that live in the houses
they've got quite a bit of car parking
off their
um off on on their sections anyway so
and they all they use the actual work
cards as well so they usually just go
and get the work cars because I've all
got their numbers on it so I know that
they hardly use the work cars if they
need it they're there available to them
thank you okay for the questions
foreign
Terry thanks for that yeah did you did
you answer my question
oh you can't answer it sorry yeah so
what's going to happen is we've got um
the uh Q Road and this street are coming
up in deliberations and we'll be
deciding on the outcome of the Strategic
parking by law for those so it's what I
suggested like I said regarding even
just to take the like something for the
people who are down that road as would
that be taken into a consideration that
is a consideration that uh people who
live there do not have exemptions yeah
yeah thank you very much thank you for
your time note of it and I'll be raised
to ask questions thank you
thank you
right okay that takes us
to the parking control law deliberations
and right do we
Russell your name's been bandied about
part of it today
councils
um I'll take the report as read Tony
points I like to highlight is um hey
it's it's obvious that uh some of the
proposed measures were not popular with
those who submitted when you see the
numbers of those who were opposed or
recommended amendments to it I like to
sort of highlight that some people
may have potentially missed what the
context was so for example Fourth Street
was talked about a lot but outside of
sit and so forth and it's only one
section of Fourth Street was actually
being proposed as some may have
misunderstood The Tint of what was being
consulted on
um the Fourth Street metering in Parker
and Hospital were the two points the
consultation that were most discussed
and he wasn't a lot of feedback
um made on the other parts that were
consulted on within the bylaw itself
our pastor and Russell if he's got any
points wants to highlight at this time
um thanks Mr chairman I'm sure there'll
be a few questions that will relate to
some of the discussion but what we've
tried to do with the options is actually
narrow the um many options down for both
um Fourth Street and for Q Road
what's the desire to actually make it
reasonably clear that it's predominantly
either the status quo what we've got or
what we're suggesting is a preferred
option it does mean but there does mean
there are other opportunities that could
be considered should Council wish to
move in that direction but happy to take
the report and answer any questions okay
I guess I'll I'll leap in as chair and
follow up with what Terry was like to
ask and that is the residence of Q Road
should they be exempt from any parking
regulations considering they live there
and not be subject to 90 minutes thanks
Mr cheers is in the report we've
considered all of those options and
their chief executive and some of my
staff had a meeting with the dhb to
actually consider what they were doing
on site to actually deal with your with
their own car parking as we know Q
Hospital site is a huge site and got
lots of parking but I guess through the
pandemic issues I've had other security
issues so they had some doors locked
they are now addressing that on the
Street we actually have three options we
have those people who want to go and
visit somebody either Ed or attend
someone at hospital but you get inside
the car Park's full or you also have the
residents who actually want to park near
the houses and you've had these
employees so we've removed two of them
and the option that we're proposing is
in fact to have on the south side which
is the side against the hospital a p180
type zone so it's a long time so you can
get there and if you've got a extended
um
appointment you can be there but it's a
scenario where the cars will turn over
during the day and on the North side
we're proposing that there'd just be
all-day parking so the residents can
handle that in front of their properties
that's that's the proposal that I think
um we considered whether we should have
residence only
um parking coupons that comes at a
reasonable overhead administratively how
you manage that yes it's possible we
haven't gone anywhere else
I'm not sure that the the advantage of
actually what it offset the uh the cost
to us given that we've got a solution
that we think it will actually work
quite satisfactory right the north side
is no no restrictions okay Leslie
thanks Mr chair I just wanted to clarify
with Russell Russell the map on
page seven of the nine
shows option two for Q Road
it's showing Nest Street with the purple
180 parks
is that meant to be the case
um well it didn't seem to quite tie in
with the words to him both sides 180. we
have had
um
time-related parking in there and that's
also a little bit so that you don't get
people who are parking and heading for
home and clogging up that area which is
reasonably tight and is reasonably close
to the school so I think it's a good
option to start with and see how we
progress
so that one if we went for it could be
re-looked depending on
exactly how it's then used we haven't
had a lot of Nest Street residents
I didn't notice a lot of Nest street we
have had no response from the district
residents as being an issue
thank you councilor Clark then Council
Ludlow thank you chair um just my issues
are around the Fourth Street one
um and in particular the the um the end
nearest
um
nearest Clyde Street
um and you've got two options here I
just wonder where there's a third option
as well which would be to have the north
side on P90 which is what you're
suggesting
um and one of them anyway with an option
two but instead of having meters on the
south side to have them free
um and I get a lot of feedback from
people who work in and around Kmart say
that as staff they are really struggling
to find car parks
um and you had that in the process where
there's other businesses in that area as
well
um that also reflected their staff are
struggling to find places over and above
those that want to work in the CBD which
I think that'll decrease as the more
gets to the end of its uh construction
so just wonder where we've got an option
there too the benefit of the P90 on the
North side as it does
keep people away from as you say from
being there long term and might need to
get into the disability centers and the
medical centers as well
um thanks Mr chair certainly any of
those auctions do work
um from a functional point of view
um the parking kiosks that are there
could be removed if that's if that's the
direction Council wishes
um we continue to suggest that parking
in that area is is still only a block
away from the from the city center
and it is an area once I think we've
stopped constructing things that we will
tend to we'll see more and more people
wanting to park but it certainly is an
option if that's the desire
thank you uh councilor scalp
no
is that Council Lush sorry yeah three
years just as far as the with your
consultations with the hospital do they
intend to put in more parking for their
own staff is that something that's on
their plan
um Mr chair I wasn't at the meeting but
my understanding was that they would be
um opening up some of the doors checking
the lighting and freeing up some of
their parking for their staff not
necessarily allocating further park for
people visiting or attending
appointments so I guess that's that is a
pressure point that I would also see
okay and just the other thing is I know
I've got a number of contacts from
people that were working there I think
it was during a one of the awards was
closed and the wardens had gone down
there it seemed as though it was an
untimely thing was that overzealousness
or is there wriggle room there to
perhaps enforce
those zones slightly less I mean have we
got much freeway with how we enforce
that
or can I not answer ask that
yeah through you Mr chair yes
um
the enforcement team were carrying out
for the first time in some time the
enforcement at that time what we will do
is work with our part with the roading
team to develop a strategy for where we
go when and how we manage that as
opposed to us just deciding so it comes
down to making sure that we keep
vehicles moving in an appropriate manner
at the various parts of the city and we
also do a lot of work around schools and
other parts of the community that have a
high parking turnover rate so it was the
first time in a long time we refunded
all those tickets and apologized to the
community and that was a good learning
for our team who were all new to that
okay brilliant thanks for the
verification
foreign
Russell
um
I can see the the concerns that people
are raising
and I can understand but what is our
purpose in planning parking
um
I mean we're not doing it as a revenue
operation I hope but we're doing it as a
traffic management and
liberating space for peoples to use I am
really concerned about an option that
allows free Parts on one side of the
street to create
um for lack of a better expression
social parking for those who need to go
to age concern or those sorts of things
which I fear might become
um
bait for people who don't want to pay
for parking and I think if we're trying
to disincentivize people from
you know
um
a parking meter avoidance we should be
saying to people if you want to if you
insist on bringing your vehicle into the
city this is the cost of doing it rather
than saying
um we're going to clap your hand and
prod you and you know is there another
way of managing social access to these
places then making some free parking
space that I fear will not be available
to those social needs clients
like a pyramid or something that they
can swipe onto the parking meter that
allows them to pack there for their
appointments I I just do worry about the
total removal of the parking meters
um Mr G that's a really interesting
really interesting and reasonably
challenging question to to respond to
um parking and its purpose is really to
keep the cars moving around the city to
give people access to those businesses
um we also have one of those fortunate I
guess advantages that you can have
all-day free parking for employees in
the city one block away from the city
center
you know
sort of in two minds to raise the issue
that as we go forward to look at climate
adaptability we will need to consider
how do we actually can how do we
encourage people not to drive everywhere
but to look at other modes and clearly
one of the options that you will need to
watch for the future is what how do you
pull the lever of parking and how close
do you get and what you want
um we've considered at length about how
we would best manage the parking in
Fourth Street and we've gone from
everything from having all-day parking
and just let it happen right through to
putting meters there and we think that
to try and find a balance to work
forward is actually to have the range
between the time restricted car park so
people can
um part there and go somewhere for a
short time or if they want to stay
longer they can pay for it
um
I think that that's the balance that
would be a good position to be in for a
period of time I do think as a city
center has is completed and the rest of
our parking and we look forward we will
need to think about
the types of um where we have currently
have parking and auto parking I think
there's another wave in the future of
actually addressing car parking
so can
can we see yeah I'm is one of the
pressures that we're finding on that
area because the bus hub is in a
different location at the moment so
therefore people
um I I know for myself for instance if I
want to go to Kmart it's quite a it's
quite a hike from actually J Smith's
um is that one of the things that people
uh because the bus hub is further away
more people from the where they want to
be working or living or whatever that
people are
using that parking in a different way
than they did before
Mr chair I don't know the complete
Dynamics but I suspect some of it will
be is that we have at the moment a
reasonably High construction Workforce
and they start relatively early so they
actually consume quite a bit of the
close by parking wow and that will that
will change as those construction sites
change so I think we'll see a slight
movement in that and actually some
normality come back to our those regions
think of itself
it's helped Council Lewis thanks Chief
Russell I don't want to Blindside you
here but in the Bible how can by law
but eight point two it's got the
councilman application including any
person residing in the facility of a
parking space and of course that packing
space is defined earlier Grant
unauthorized vehicle permit for that
person entitling that person the sole
ride to park a vehicle in that parking
space during study period and such
occasion so the conditions as the
council May determine if any ideas what
what probably strict criteria would it
might or have you any ideas what the
criteria would be so Mr chairman that
that purpose of that Clause is
specifically in there so should we wish
to have parking permits issued that we
actually have the powers to do so I
guess my recommendation in the report is
that I don't believe 4q Road it's the
right solution at this time it could
actually be around high schools or other
places where we have really high
congestion of parking that that might
actually apply better but that's the
purpose of the Clause I'm not suggesting
we use it thanks very much
uh Russell just a point of clarification
when we do come to to vote on this uh
option two for the Q Road Ness Street
one option two is silent as far as I can
see on this
um
it it mentions parking in option one
finesse but an option two
uh the outcome for this street
the map shows purple on both oh yeah
just it might yeah okay it shows on the
map but not in written
I believe we actually had provided a
bigger map that I could read as well
that we would have so when we look at
what's written for option two it says uh
p180 South Side
all day parking north side
now imagine that's for QQ Road isn't it
that's correct so as when you when you
look at that paragraph
um that option too what does it say
about in this street
difference
just so when we do put the motion I just
want to make sure that this street
it's it's not specifically mentioned but
I believe we should include it in as
being the p180
on this street
okay that's what the map shows no no
it's okay I just Rodeo Council clap
um Russell just on page a to the record
on board books 51.
uh see you're clarifying the police
vehicles are only Exempted for parking
rules for Urgent police work and I have
some concerns with that I guess
um
at a time when we've got a lot of minor
crime going on around the city you want
police to be more visible
um I just think it gets it stretches
their patience to expect them to be
around our community on non-urgent work
um and then have to jump out and go 50
meters down the road to put in some
money into a parking meter I think that
it's a stretched too far for me so
just I guess I'm signaling that
any comment on that Russell
Mr Chew we we changed that just to make
sure that it that it was reasonably
clear that when they're on appropriate
Police business you know we use just
have used the word urgent
um I guess if they're there for uh
planned or otherwise then it
um we could remove that and just have it
for any use in a marked marked vehicle
but not all police vehicles are
obviously made
I don't know of any situation where
we've actually ticketed anybody in a
police car but um
ninja will be able to tell us that I
wouldn't think so
okay
um councilor supper then councilor
cracker
I know
conversation with age concerned that
there was a bit of talk about the over
80s parking exemption
and the fact that it is not well known
and the fact it would seem that age
concern expressed
a bit of surprise
um how how much publicity can we
incorporate into whatever we decide
today that advertises that over 80s
parking exemption further
I guess that's an opportunity for
Council to continue to promote that um
it's not something new in our in our
community it's something that's been
there for an extended period of time
and it is an opportunity for the over
80s to pack on street so um that's
certainly something we could could raise
and certainly with age consume they're
now much more aware of that and they
will most likely promote it
most people over the age 80 who I'm
aware of
um line up pretty quick to get a
so can you indicate how many over 80s
permits
are out there already because it's still
display in the windows is it not are the
over 80s Prima Mr chair now we've moved
on a little bit we've got with the new
system we're able to record the the
license plate and I guess we're still
working in
um group manager Trudy might be able to
tell me how many and I my recollection
is about there's about 300 permits
where they were but once again we a
number of people will have the permit
issued it is for a two-year period but
if they um
cease to have a driver's license we're
unable to drive then their permit should
be
rescinded but it's reliant on them
actually coming into Council and and
returning it so
so that is a fairly low number
for our population
thank you
Council Cricket oh thank you Mr chair
um I've got a couple of Randall
questions I think somewhat
um some other places across the country
we have a provision or the council has
provided for
individuals to obtain licenses to occupy
car parks for an extended period
and I know that enough recent judges we
have it's 15 a day if you wish to hire
out the park
is there any kind of plan for licensing
or something like that or hiring out the
parks on a longer term basis to pop up
things such as pocket packs or a scooter
stands or bike stands
um such as the ones really similar to
the ones that you know what I'm talking
about Russell you've seen them before
um she
at least there's two elements to that is
that we haven't necessarily encouraged
people to lease on a long term a council
one street park for a commercial
activity and we provide car parking on
the street and we don't necessarily we
control that the decision to make to
withdraw that car park to use for other
facilities for our community is
something that rests with Council and we
can do so and I guess we remove those
car parks and actually change them into
whatever we want whenever we want
um
and it's reasonably straightforward and
we don't necessarily charge yourselves
however the um for
um we used to have meter bags that of
course we don't have any meters to put
the bags on anymore so we now have a
system where you can effectively
um pay pay for a page parked for a day
from a commercial basis and that person
can park either outside a specific
business or anywhere in the on-street
parking Zone
and it's priced in a way that it's not
necessarily encouraging people to pay
for them at all times it's there for a
commercial it's there if the Builder's
doing some work and they need to park
close by I guess one of our things we
continue to monitor
is to make sure that's not abused by I
guess the trade sector of the community
because it is actually in good faith
that we do so
um if you packed all day at a cut a
meter which we don't encourage people by
the would the charge becomes quite a lot
more than fifteen dollars but because of
a the trade type activity that's
supporting a business for a short time
we actually have set it at that price at
this time
yeah yeah
um so is that being somewhat prohibitive
of um activity like that so if we were
to decide that it would be fantastic or
somebody in the city was to decide it'd
be fantastic to bring e-scooters here
and they set up some charging stations
or docking stations on trailers and not
wanted to hire out a a park for a
long-term period perhaps they move them
around town or it's a bike stand it's
Community activation project
um there's lots of benefits to those
things so that it
does this mean that it's too prohibitive
for people to undertake I would I would
suggest that if someone came along and
wanted to put an e-scooter stand that
had a charging and had advertising on it
and those things and all those things we
felt were appropriate then charging them
would be absolutely appropriate and we
could set council could set a fee
whatever
um how it worked through that
um I guess what we've done is where it's
actually been for Community good and
it's not been for a specific business
the last thing we want to try to have is
you're allowed to park here if you've
got a green scooter or a pink scooter
um it's I guess if you're there and
you've you've got a bike stand you're
allowed to park your bike no matter who
we bought from so I guess from that
perspective going forward I think there
are some of the uh future challenges
that we could have uh if and when
e-scooters arrive in our city and sorry
to continue that
um the the similar sort of thing could
apply with the car park long-term
leasing if that you wanted to use that
as the extension of your footpath and I
know we're obviously treating the um
okay uh the footpath
um stuff this afternoon as well so if
you had you know uh
clear walkway but then you wanted to put
seating or extend your outdoor area for
Cafe and that kind of thing by taking up
a couple of those car parts with the
appropriate barriers
Etc
are we stopping a bit from happening I
believe you've you're heading in the
right direction by saying as if that if
we have a footpath it's not that doesn't
meet all the requirements for a
disability sector and you can't fit the
tables in the right place and they want
to consume some car Parks then that
would be a consideration Council might
want to take and they might take it as a
balance they might say is there a is
there a community benefit here or is it
all commercial if it's an all commercial
then you can make a commercial decision
about the use of the car park and the
bylaw does permit that
um that's it I guess sitting in setting
a new fee but all those things are um
are capable
and I think they are the forward-looking
piece of we we want to do that because
as we get onto the footpath um
it's about setting some rules that we
can actually
balance the community's desires and
needs
thank you thanks Alex
um councilor Arnold then councilor Clark
all right I've got a couple of questions
um
have you noticed a decrease in actual
people parking in this area or this is a
proposal isn't it or are the meters
there now I honestly haven't looked
certainly in Fourth Street and other
places where where we have installed to
parking uh the paid parking in more
recent times where people have had free
parking they have moved and changed and
I guess that's
um
people by nature don't want to pay for
car Parks so they don't have to and and
the way the parking is in those metered
spaces so the the use of those spaces
have decreased and I guess that's what I
was referring to earlier is that I think
in time in the next
I'm thinking the next couple of years we
need we need to sit back and once the
city has
the build components in place see how
that parking is moving with because
we've got bigger car Parks now let's see
what happens and that's the time to
readdress some of those issues and and
see how we can use parking as a as a
positive for the city but at the moment
I guess we're just trying to control
these spaces and be consistent do you
not think there's a question you don't
think it might be better to perhaps
introduce us in the future as opposed to
now because we're probably two or three
years away before the invercargill
city's finished and all those buildings
that I'm looking at on Fourth Street
there they all have customer parking so
there's no parking required for people
there so your proposing that people are
going to pack your car there and then
walk into town that's what you're this
was The Proposal that we proposed in the
last vital review except that we didn't
have our Maps aligned and some some
customers pointed out that we weren't
doing it the way it should be so hence
we brought this back and and got some
further feedback on it
the other question was um I'm presuming
this goes right down to 11th Street
Little Elm Street
you've stopped at sort of halfway on the
Block here this parking method so this
this park the paid packed all the way
down to the Dell Street currently that's
the the current bylaw that has that and
all we're really saying is the piece
that we identified or was identified to
us that wasn't consistent with how we
had set it out was the piece between
um this street and and Clyde Street so
the rest of the the rest of the bylaw as
it stands is still
um is unchanged and un and isn't
proposed to change and my last question
last question is um like um
Carolyn Weston and I mentioned is there
any intention to increase the number of
meters in town actually instead of
having one on a block so you've got to
walk half a block to use it
I know you can do it on your iPhone if
you're or your your mobile phone if
you're that way inclined but a lot of
people aren't so is there any intention
to have more a bit closer together
we're seeing an evolving change is that
the number of people who are using um
the
parking kiosk and the other features is
actually growing in time you know um
what we've done is we have put in and
we've got pay by pay by plate which
means you can go to any of the kiosks on
street and pay for it so you don't have
to walk away from the kiosk away from
your destination to do it so you could
walk
to the destination during your 10
minutes of
your free time and then actually do it
on any of the machines you come past as
you walk
um
what we what we're trying to do is
balance the I guess it's a it's a it's a
cost efficiency thing that's about how
many you put in where do you put them in
against you know they're not inexpensive
they are they have at times have been
subject to vandalism so it's just trying
to find a balance of the right place and
the right and we have used the
experience of our provider who who
nationally do this
we think we've got them right I guess
it's a learning curve we've only we're
only reasonably
um early in the life of these these
products so I think yeah I'm quite I'm
quite comfortable there are places where
it's doesn't look as obvious
um
but I guess my experience would be is
what do you guys see when you go to a
different town and if you go to
Christchurch you see an empty Park you
park your car and then you're looking to
decide what you've got to do here
um I think in the people are getting out
of the habit now of saying every Park
had a parking meter so we've sort of
changing a little bit so yeah instead of
half a block though but I'm just
thinking if you just had free parking on
Fourth Street there again you could
actually just free up six parking meters
end up around here
um some of the things is that you are
walking to a destination and these are
typically in the direction of your
destination so we've thought quite a lot
about where people are going and how to
actually make sure when you're walking
there you actually are getting close to
to one potential we're quite comfortable
with the number we've got out there
which is
um
80 80
kiosks which is a summer ratio across
the country you're six here on Fourth
Street
I thank you Russell okay Council Clerk
and Russell um just in relation to
e-bikes I think um Alec fraised some
issues around that
um
we don't we don't seem to be
accommodating the parking of e-bikes in
town and we're going to Great Lengths
about cars and other vehicles and I
waited before and I just wonder where we
tied them whether it's part of this by
law which talks about cycle Lanes
and we've got some overarching desires
to encourage people to walk or bike into
the inner city area but there's no safe
place to
to um Park your bike up and so good I
mean a good example is most e-bikes
range between three and ten thousand
dollars worth
um and most people that ride e-bikes and
I'm one of them would not bring their
bike into town and tie it to a lamp post
or something similar because it could be
stolen so the CCTV is an issue
um but we don't want them with the
narrowing of foot pass or some of the
accessibility issues that we had people
submitting on before to be congesting
bikes being tied to poles and we just
seem to have nothing
um Council park has raised a really
interesting question and there are two
projects that are currently um the ICL
development study block development does
have a specific area for a lot a lock up
um cycle Park
and we as Council have the opportunity
to actually build with some eco-funding
a lockup e-bike facility and we're still
negotiating with h j Smith's to actually
build it inside there specifically as
Council Clark points out so that you can
have I guess greater security and I
guess that leads on to how do we make
safer places if we want people to cycle
and that will be the next wave of um
suggestion and it's certainly not
something that's missed in our city
center but we've got to find
the right location that's covered secure
all of those things that will actually
encourage people to bring their five
thousand dollar bike to town
thank you
okay councilor seven yeah Russell just
one last question on option two for
Fourth Street
so you're suggesting part
90.
what was the reasoning for the choice
rather 90 rather than 120.
90 minutes was seen to be a reasonable
time that people could effectively walk
to and from City Center and shop for an
hour or thereabouts it also gives the
um enforcement team I guess it's about
them returning in those time frames too
and and our P90 was thought to be
probably the right balance between p60
was too short and we thought p120 was
probably too long so it was just really
a
um
an experience an observation that we
felt was probably about the right place
to be in
okay Council Clark just one quick uh
clarification I thought I read somewhere
that age concern thought that the P90
was a little bit short for their clients
but people going for Midday meals and to
socialize as well did I pick that up
wrong
for radio it won't cost them a thing
sorry they're over 80 it won't cost them
anything yeah but there's people under
80 that go there too as well
I think that you'll find that that's
probably at the right time as they
typically it's about an hour and a half
that well that's the time they normally
are there for so we can confirm if that
was in the future if that's a problem we
could
um extend it so if they were there
longer for some reason so they'll have
the meal and they socialize uh are we in
there asking those people to go out and
pick up their car somewhere and flick it
somewhere else
is that the option the P90 pack means
you're supposed to only Park the 90
minutes yeah okay
Council kit yeah I just want to throw a
bit of light on age concern
um they have midday meals but in the
afternoon sometimes I play balls or have
a concert housing
Etc so 90 minutes would be a bit short
very short indeed because so maybe you
should be talking about 240 minutes
all those options are possible but
equally the parks aren't specifically
and only designed for age consume they
are there for the community to use it
could well be the case that if there's
lots of people it's not a guaranteed
Park if you're if you're attending
age consumer there's actually a free
park for people to park for 90 minutes
um it's a similar time that we have a
free parking on the um roof of the
living Street Camp
okay Council sober thanks Mr chair
um
ask you if if we are going to move
option two that the 90 has changed to
120 just to test the mood of the meeting
I my own feeling is when I consider the
reasoning behind that um suggestion that
120 would be a more reasonable
usage for the people we're talking about
yeah I intend to break those up so that
would be an opportunity so yeah I think
with enough deliberation there so um
what I'm going to do is
um I'm going to move recommendations one
through to five
um to get those out of the roads so uh
do I have a secondary for that if that's
okay with everyone counselor Scott I've
put that motion all in favor say aye aye
against that takes us now to
recommendation six now we've got two
options here so what I'll do first is
we're going to do the Fourth Street one
which cancel the server arrays so option
one for Fourth Street is Mika meter
parking on North and South Side versus
option two which is north side currently
at P90 and South Side as being Zone one
meter parks
so
right cancel this over
thanks Mr cheers so I would um
be prepared to move option two for
Fourth Street but replacing the 90 with
120. right do I have a second ever there
so
let's cook you're seconding net okay
right so we're gonna cancel clack chair
could I suggest an option three as well
which is the north side of a 120. which
is what my colleague suggested in free
car parking on the south side as opposed
to meters well at the moment we have
translation yeah yeah
so
what I'm gonna do is uh okay we've got
that on the floor uh Council of sopas so
I'm actually going to go now to the
queue Nest Street
one
go ahead and get a motion for either
option one or two
whatever so councilor cyber again
prepared to move option two as it says
okay I have a second for that
councilor Clark
right
um
as far as the modification
the first one
uh the clarification for councilor super
raised was that she's just uh altered
the timer of P90
to 120.
I have a council clock
foreign
[Music]
the south side to free parking yeah
okay well that is actually not
contradictory to what councilor sober
does so I can also
it's not because that's just talking
about the south side
okay so with the clarification through
you I'd like to include
they are
so there will be
um yeah how do we deal with this
because we're actually altering the
south side
and the north side from two different
people
so I'm gonna put these separately so
those who are opposed I need a second
Earth for councilor Clark's motion
please
councilor Arnold okay so I'm going to
put these separately
South Side alone if my motion is voted
for there would be some problem in
putting yeah I see that so what I'm
going to do mine would need
yeah yeah yeah I'm just looking at
separating south side and North Side God
you guys are great to me yeah sorry can
I suggest you that you put councilor
soakers um
um recommendation and people know that
there's an alternative recommendation
now and that that's defeated then we get
we've got another option to go to okay
and it was accepted then that's why
that's the way no no we'll do that yeah
we'll do that okay so what I'm going to
do is uh
put those recommendations so councilor
sopa has uh for the Fourth Street one is
just altered the north side p120 and has
gone for an unaltered option two for the
Q Road near street so I'm going to put
that motion as it sits on the screen all
those in favor
hi hi
yeah I'm going to support that
so count of hands we have one two three
four five six seven eight that is past I
think my vote recorded against it
because I don't feel it's enough parking
time for the elderly outside the 120.
yep okay right Division and uh if you
note um and you want the reason recorded
yeah like as I said no no I just so it's
not a matter of debating it you want the
reason yes I do please yes I do that's
fine
yeah
and then Council Clan and I'll have mine
recorded against as well for the reason
of that for the reason of the freak yeah
we can just note the reasons it makes it
actually provides Clarity later on thank
you
hey thanks guys
um okay we're a tenth of the way through
so we're on the way
so
the chief executive acting has suggested
uh 5 p.m break so looking at what sneaks
off the clock is we have the cemeteries
and Crematory crematorium bylaw which I
think we could do
okay right
who wishes just oh here we go that's
quick okay it's all yours uh thank you
Mr chair and again I'll take the report
this one is read uh the consultation was
light on this boil or however that was
not unexpected
um I'd like to note that we did some
some solid pre-engagement with the
funeral directors in Monumental Masons
and during that pre-engagement they gave
us some good feedback and we used that
to help
make some changes so we went up a
consultation we weren't expecting to be
a lot of feedback come back our way uh
fundamentally little has changed from
what we currently do now to what we're
proposing it's just more of a structural
change within the documents itself
um that's all you have to say anything
from you Caroline you no I'll just
reiterate the um
the engagement that we did with the
funeral directors we held quarterly
meetings with them as a group we did
them um pre uh pre-writing the
guidelines and then post writing the
guidelines so they had the opportunity
to feedback and then we
um asked them to submit and those that
did submitted in favor so we we feel
like we gave good consultation and
discussion with them on on this in in
their setting
okay
here I'm happy to remove the full
recommendations
um I think the pre-engagement has made a
difference and as Karen just said the
submissions that we've received are in
support
I would second that so before we put the
motion cancel the crack it and you end
your
um you're waving they're going
Council Clark just just some
clarification
um in the part that talks about the um
requirements for to have Monumental work
approved I just wanted to know how wide
that is
um like if you think about Sam Cusack
he's got a head's done and it's quite
unique it's made out of glass and it's
at the time was probably quite
um quite a one-off is that restricted
under these vinyls or
with the um
when the Monumental Masons Association
or somebody approved by them have some
reservations about that
so Chad the um there was a New Zealand
standard for headstones in Cemetery
um monuments so any uh structure any
installation has to adhere to that
anyway however it's designed and the
installation just ensures that it's
installed safely okay so they have to
meet the standard and then we're saying
we'd like it to be installed safely yep
foreign
okay with that uh we've had it moved and
seconded I'm going to put the motion all
those in favor
that is carried right I think before
five we can squeeze in the uh reshaping
streets regulatory changes and then what
that will do is bring us fresh into the
footpath management policy so
right
Russell do you want to lead in
[Applause]
or Leslie
I'll start okay um
thanks counselors this is really an
information paper to actually I guess
highlight that there are some changes
being proposed by umutahi
of which we wish to respond to the
question I guess their survey by the
19th which is this Friday it's really
looking to actually free up uh he gets
their hands a little bit to actually be
able to do some of the things councilor
Cricket talked about earlier about being
able to
use the streets in a bit more of a
friendly way at the moment
we often find when people want to have a
street party or something in their area
that we've got to go through a road stop
a rogue temporary road closing type
process which is a bit uh drawn and
extended and this gives us uh this is
planned to give us a lot more tools to
be able to do that so that's really what
the driver of the fundamental of the
regulatory changes are and
um and the second part is really just to
highlight that the Tempe traffic
management process which is that which
you see all the orange cones around town
is actually
fundamentally isn't changing but it was
changing its focus to be much more
closely aligned to the health and safety
act so from a risk basis
in essence we are saying that there's no
change to what people need to do but the
con but we're actually asking
um all those people who do things in our
road to actually meet the standard they
should be currently meeting so there is
a little bit of a step up um it's
placing a bit more Reliance on people to
think about a risk process
and I guess this paper just tries to
bring that to your attention so you're
aware of whether I guess that shift is
occurring across the community to
encourage people to use our streets for
just more than cars
questions any questions for us all yes
councilor Clark um two two issues um
first on page two of the report
um biggest belief why we continue to
support a wakakatahi commitment to Road
Zero by whatever it is 20 40 20 50. I
mean so long as you've got cars on the
roads we're always going to have accents
and they're always going to have this
it'll be a far better
um Vision I guess to have a reduction in
the amount of harm we have on the roads
as opposed to having a a result that
nobody actually thinks that they're
going to get to but the other issue for
me is the issue of traffic management
and I've heard from Parks staff
that um it's hard to do a lot of the
work that we do around the inner city
because we need to get traffic
management
um contractors to do that traffic
management side of it I said well you
know why don't we do our own
and the and the response back from some
of the management was well actually we
do train people up but then traffic
management people go and poach our staff
because they pay way more and I just
wonder that going forward in the next
six months or so whether we give some
thought internally about how we
um can train up around people internally
and retain them without losing them and
that might be there may be some pay
increases for that motion because it
allows us to then manage our work
because one of the managers told me
recently that you can plan to do some
work in the on one of the roads and you
get the training traffic management book
that it takes a month to get something
ready to go and then it pours with rain
and then you're another month before you
get the get the opportunity again so
just wonder internally with this I'm
ability for us to train and and retain
more more importantly they're just an
idea Novella Point cancel that no it's
fine you raise a good point because
um uh basically you've got to signify
that there's worker hit and you see that
yeah and then you provide clear Carnage
cone settings to avoid people getting
near you now it would make sense that
our very busy
um Park's team should be able to do that
on their own you know and obviously
you've got to if you have to file
notification that's happening or
whatever they can do that and it seems
very double-handed and
and Ott that we've got to get you know
sort of separate especially for
run-of-the-mill stuff different if you
are perhaps chopping down trees that are
going to fall on a Kelvin Street house
it might be a bit different
um but yeah I understand where you're
coming from Council that yeah just
wonder if there's a bit of a difference
in the role so between
uh compliance which is what the parking
staff are doing an stmp work which is
something that requires qualification
yeah
yeah I think it's a really it's a valid
issue that we're going to face in many
areas where we're facing competition
from the from the private sector and
there and so that qualification you're
talking about which is about you know
real the the people in the Parks team
would they gain those qualifications by
whatever they are actual parking uh us
Parks I'm talking about not parking so
this is Parks doing their doing their
work around
so Mr chairman there's a couple of
things here we might part of my team
manage the corridor and part of our role
is to actually manage the corridor
safely
so part of our role is to actually
receive information from outside parties
whether they be for projects that
Council are running or projects that
anyone else is running which include our
Parks colleagues
and make sure they've made a reasonable
standard and then monitor that so that's
what we would call a traffic management
controller so that's our TMC roles
um
any business suffers the same that
sometimes some of your best people who
who get trained to do specific tasks
become more valuable to others and I
guess traffic management is just one of
those areas where there is a skill
shortage it's just one of those areas
where some people are really good at
doing it and it is certain in area we
were asking um
more focused about being safe on the
roads I guess that's what we're trying
to do we're just trying to make sure
that the roads are safe
and probably for a long time
um the country as a whole
um has has demonstrated that there have
been a number of deaths and therefore
the work sites aren't safe so this is
just an alignment with the health and
safety act
in a similar in a similar nature I'm
sure if you've had your roof painted or
your roof replaced you know 20 years ago
they might have just stood on your roof
and not worried about it now you pay for
square foot and now you pay for the
whole 10 yards this is just another one
of those situations where we've
identified some risks and ideally I
guess we would like to retain all of our
skilled staff that we train every time
anytime but the market forces do Prevail
so
just like that yeah just reinforcing
what you said before Geo about
um the desire to have that skill
internally
and some time ago I asked our chief
executive at a meeting
um why we don't have a lot of colored
plants in the the little Louis strips
that go down the middle of the roads and
she quite rightly said well it's not as
easy to maintain them once you put them
in because traffic management you just
can't go along and weed them anymore
you've got to have cones out and as
Russell Smith does the safety things so
the retention is not a matter of keeping
qualified staff is what we pay them
and if we need to pay two or three or
whatever third needs to be x amount of
dollars more than we traditionally have
so that we have better flexibility in
managing the inner city stuff that we
need to manage
so if I thought one last question before
I get someone to move this and that is
uh with all this training traffic
management out and about I'm seeing it's
all nicely laid out but there's no one
working
now that's frustrating thing that I've
had a lot of feedback about the roads
are shut down residents only
everything's like it's a nightmare yet
there is no one working so as are they
are people allowed to put that sort of
um sort of uh pull that blockage out
there and not do anything at the time
and just say I I'll just come along
whenever I want to and do the work
Mr chair a relatively short answer that
question says that when they apply they
have an attended site in an unattended
site so they typically have two
different layouts that they actually
look for
um
and often when they've left it out
they've um they have done so because
it's um there's a feature or something
an open trench or something that may not
necessarily be always obvious we do also
work try to work with them really
closely to make sure that they don't
impede traffic unnecessarily as you
would say because the frustration
drivers have as you you drive through
you know certainly in an open Highway a
site with no one about the next site
typically you drive through people tend
to not respect and I guess that's the
big thing that we face is actually
drivers actually respecting the work
sites because there are workers they are
part of our community
um it's an ongoing issue that we just
need to continue to work with them no no
thank you for that okay right
um can I have we've got two
recommendations here that the report be
received and that the transport team
complete the consultation survey for the
Ministry of Transport oh sorry
okay Ministry of Transport reshaping
strict regulatory changes and submit
this by the 19th of September this year
that's going to be moved by Evelyn and
second by Leslie and I'll put that
motion all those in favor
aye against that is carried right I'm
gonna adjourn the meeting for a break
okay
okay we're underway now we're gonna re
I'm going to re-jiggle the agenda
because we have Mr Green here and he was
featuring in the activities report and
rather than having wait I'm going to
jump to the activities report and we'll
get on with that now so
first
item in the activities reporters from
Leisure and Recreation who wouldn't like
this weekend yeah I'll just quickly
touch on Parks and Recreation Richard
can talk about the Aquatic Services
sorry Richard
um so probably the only key point to
note there is around the engagement that
Council staff are currently leading
around the Sandy Point Master planning
um what we've noted in the activity
report
um already from Community feedback some
really positive aspects uh and
recognition of the value that this uh
space has for the community
um also identifying some emerging Trends
but also some concerns that the next
Council are going to have to deal with
as we take the master planning exercise
into the reserve management plan which
will occur first half of next year but
I'm
I've met happy to take any questions on
Parks and Recreation or happy to pass
straight over to Richard to talk about
product services
right Richard where are you just over
here yeah three Mr chair the uh uh
monthly uh
participation visitor stats of the uh
Specialists continue to Trend towards a
positive direction we note that the
comparing it's still really difficult to
compare to the same period last year
because the inconsistencies with
pandemic and everything else we also
note that in this July we did have a
period of um activity which was uh pause
for maintenance as well but on the on
the whole trending towards recovery and
doing well at the um special so any
questions happy to answer
any questions on Spanish Palace
that would take us now to
infrastructure road maintenance
operations
Russell
no nothing to
I think we can take the bulk of this
report red or heavy to go to Russell and
John yeah we'll go to City streetscapes
okay so stage one so thanks Mr chair I
thought it was a an opportunity to I
guess
um
bring some further information about
East and Don Street we've been
um in that space for the last 12 months
and
um have made some significant progress
and
um I thought it would be a good
opportunity for all the chair of air
City Center governance group to perhaps
um give some reflection and I guess
that's one of the advantages of having
that group is that
um John sees from I guess a different
lens sometimes he's he's seen from the
commercial in the business side of the
the city
um
John cool thank you oh thank you Mr
chair for rearranging the agenda it's um
I thought I was going to be sitting down
there listening to
to whatever was happening for the next
hour and a half so thank you for that
um
thank you all it's good to be back
um it's been a while so I think really I
just want to have a little bit of
informal chat we'll just really sort of
share some thoughts um I know you're
busy you've been a lot on we don't need
to take too much time
um and you would have been kept up to
date obviously the projects are very
visible and everyone is no doubt been
circulating and checking to see what the
progress is almost on a daily basis and
it's certainly very heartwarming to walk
down this street in those new spaces and
to get the feedback both from history
and Dawn Street that we're getting so
um I think I've got a license to drive
maybe not
we just got one if we can thank you so I
really just want to cover on a
reflection on what's been achieved um
just talk a little master plan through
to stage one
stage two plea for continuity
um I'll explain that
um and then I think some acknowledgments
that are due for this project so um
thank you so master plan to stage one
streetscapes
you made a commitment to developing a
master plan late 2019
um we selected those those Consultants
during lockdown and April 2020
seems so recent really and yet we've
done so much in that time the master
plan then was delivered and signed off
February 21 so really not that long ago
we had signed off the master plan and
when um I think a major step there for
the city and then establish the
principles stage one streetscapes design
programmed and set to be delivered March
23 and while I guess it would have been
nice to have hit that initial plan of
December 22 it was always ambitious and
I think if we look at three months over
the that um
duration of a master plan to completion
of stage one three months isn't a big
slippage I think we should keep that
proportional relative to the scope of
what's been undertaken
um the combination of that work the
lived experience of doing it
um the plan all inform stage two design
and obviously that's well Advanced and
provides that framework for adapting to
changes in scope and there's going to be
changes in scope around distinction what
the place and potentially what you
decide to do finally on esk and Kelvin
so that the framework is there the
thought process is there there's a lot
to um and a lot of the work has been
done I think it's appropriate to um
think about the report card of how we've
done
so we've got some quality outcomes and
that's really was the goal
um right from the outset we drew I guess
from previous projects that were really
meant to be planning and really became
beautification this is different and I
think that the team have delivered on
that there are quality outcomes that is
well on its way to developing this
number one goal of an aspirational
environment that improves pride in the
city
um and I think you know if the
interesting one wants to debate that but
I think that that was very clearly in
our minds and I say I think we're well
on the way to that
the big story I think from a governance
group perspective of what has come out
of the last
couple of years of development is the
degree of collaboration between all of
the projects one of the things we set
out to achieve was for the public to
perceive one big project and that again
I think has been delivered on that
really the public uh
you know of the mind that ICL the
streets even the hotel and iot and then
Richardson Tower is one big project that
is rejuvenating in the city the way that
those projects have worked together the
fact that people have played well
together and it has happened there's a
great reflection on all the people that
have been involved so to me
collaboration is one of the major wins
out of this series of projects
connectivity it's one of the things
Russell and I talk about a lot is the
connectivity between all the different
parts we think is probably as good as
it's been
um it is probably a big Improvement on
previous projects the the community are
connected to it the different players
are connected to it and so far that has
not really proven to have you know
there'd be any issues around that so
again I think a good win for all the
people concerned
and the other big one that you've heard
me talk about here quite a bit was this
needed to be a catalyst for private
investment Council cannot do this on its
own it needs the private investors to
come to the party and I'm pretty
confident what we're seeing and what
we're hearing and it will take time that
that is going to happen and I think
again that's a major win on this report
card
so I think in the main it's all pretty
good
stage two and I know there are differing
points of view
but I'm going to make a plea for
continuity
stage one takes us a long way to where
we wanted to go as in a city but we're
not done and it can't be the end
of this program
without going on stage two we will never
realize the full benefits of stage one
so from my point of view that really is
a no-brainer
it's critical to the process that this
continuity of resources to keep it alive
to keep one handwriting it's really
important that we don't allow the
resources that have been assembled to
sort of just fall away from us and that
we end up sort of bringing in new teams
of people who will want to bring in new
ideas which is great in itself but what
we will do is lose the handwriting and
that's really important because one of
the things we're trying to do here is
build a brand for the inner city and if
we keep on changing the handwriting we
don't get this continuity of design
design intent of finishes of
tradesmanship and all the work that goes
into bringing this together
we will not achieve that
and I think we have to be quite
hard-nosed about that is if you want to
realize the full benefits of the
investment you have to deliver a
finished cohesive product doesn't matter
what business you're in and it's really
important that we don't lose the
opportunity that's in front of us
it's really
um I guess that was the main thing I
want to come along and talk to about
today was we have an opportunity we've
done really well we've gone a long way
but we're not done there's a bit to do
and as we move into a new political
cycle and as new decisions be made what
we do need is to make sure that there's
some cohesiveness into what comes next
so I think it's equally important that
we acknowledge
the contributions that have gone in to
date I want to congratulate Council for
the courage to go down the master plan
route it would have been easy not to
um has seemed like a whole lot of
Theory uh and they create it's important
that if they have the same courage to
keep the master plan alive the
commitment to Renewal not compromising
on quality is something that I think is
really important that again we
congratulate you on the project team
that's the ICC team from the staff the
Consultants that have come in the
contractors they've all worked
incredibly well and again I think that
their efforts should be acknowledged
the other projects whether it be Ico or
Richardson Tower or langlands or any
other work that's going on the
infrastructure upgrades that are going
on under the streets again we should
acknowledge that again everyone has
worked very well towards the same goal
the city center business Community
um you know most of our early
conversations were about the fearfulness
of what was going to happen
you know anyone who was concerned what
was going to happen the car Parks were
gone that people couldn't park outside
well
when you go and talk to these people
that is not the way it played out some
of them had their best December's ever
last Christmas
um they're excited they're starting to
see the benefits that we talked about
the starting to see the benefits of the
extra car Parks starting to get the feel
of what this street is going to look
like
people are saying to me daily are we
really going to let the cars back in
this street and I say if we'd pitched
that at the beginning we wouldn't have
got over the ground
um but you know that's a really
interesting movement in the community
towards that but the city center
business Community have been great I
really want to single out
um Kirsten Harper who has done the
facilitation of between all the pieces
of the project one person has managed to
open doors and keep everyone moving with
the support of Russell and his team so
again that collaboration with great
South and through that involvement has
been tremendous
and then just everyone else who
facilitated the stakeholder engagement a
lot of people working very hard to get
people to see past the inconvenience and
everything else so you know really just
to wrap up
um where we're at governance group has
got work to keep on doing and we move
into activation phase with Richard and
his team we start looking towards stage
two we're obviously anxious to get some
updates on that when
the time is right but again I just think
it's good to sit back celebrate the win
celebrate what's been achieved be
excited about it don't worry about the
three months overrun it's nothing in the
program of the things to come so that's
all ready and just happy to answer any
questions thanks John okay I'm going to
open up for questions
yes Marcus yeah thanks for every
encouraged by that just uh in the two
years it's happened Ram raids and all
that's come across and I see that
there's a cell phone shop next to
Bernie's shop they're putting in a
pop-up is that does that fit within the
whole scheme is that something that
we've worked out or is that within
keeping with that are we worried about
it yeah
yeah ruin the look of the street
um I think there's there's a long way to
go there's a lot of issues around
um you know brim raids and whether you
can do
um barriers and things and there's
what's under the street and what's under
the footpath it's another consideration
for Russell and his team
um right now it's copycat I would
suggest mostly
um
we talk about it within our own business
uh We've thought about it for is there a
need to try and protect East Street I
guess with at each end because you're
not going to do that on the store-based
store basis
I think it's evolving
um I think if it gets worse as
everyone's going to say well why didn't
we think of that why didn't we do
something about it but there's a heck of
a lot of work would be involved
um and I think you know you really got
to have
a little bit of experience of it it
becomes a problem we'll respond
but I think to just think you're going
to do a whole lot of work put a whole
lot of bollards in a preemptive I think
would be premature boat shops are put in
bothers yeah where they can and they're
allowed to do that that's fine is it uh
that's beyond my sphere but I think one
of the things you'll think about whose
property is it on so if they've got
reasons 10 goes there's one thing but
then what's under the ground
um or the proximity to the rest of the
infrastructure would be an issue so I
would expect for us will you speak for
it but it would be on a case-by-case
basis Mr it certainly would be on a
case-by-case basis and we would not
um we would have to work through a
process if it wanted to be in the street
if they want to put in their own
property they can do so we can't we
can't stop them
for example we've got them at the back
of the gunshot yeah because that was and
that was again on our own property from
day one different but the money Street
or Tay Street yeah
for the questions Council Scott
um through each year John firstly a
fantastic result so far and the
community feedback has been um stunning
from the very small to the elderly
um and the right player have been fully
behind the project I think that's just
grown in momentum I'm really enjoying
the um plea for continuity that you've
come out with today and I think it's
really important that this community
understands that this current Council
this current council is supporting
stage two obviously going forward and I
would
say to those that are not and perhaps
there's some campaigning going on
currently around that and some of our
mural hopefuls to stop stage two the
community should be aware of that
because just on the points that you've
made I think it's incredibly important
for the long-term development of this
city that we complete the project we've
started so
um the media should pick up on that and
make our community very aware very aware
of who is opposing because this Council
has committed themselves to stage two
and thank you as you know I'm apolitical
um but um
I I guess my and I appreciate the
comments and the support I guess the key
here is continuity of intellectual
property and when you have changes in
people and you have you know when it's
all a process and I get all that but
ultimately it's always about the people
um you know anyone will talk about the
system my experience it's always about
the people so I think that's really
important that we keep the people who
have been critical to this program
engaged in it and keep some continuity
and if there's compromise well at the
end of the day
you know they'll be out there'll be
decisions made but what we don't want to
do is compromise quality and again this
is what I come back to
set out to create a quality product we
believe we've delivered a quality
product let's not enter the world of
compromise
Counselor Clark well John I guess he's
one of the person I'm talking about
so my my view of the world and stage two
is going forward
if I have some influence and that's not
so I will have is that I have some
struggle with going east on S Street
um I like the concept of um extending a
corridor between Dawn and esque but I
can't understand why we would want to
build or design a people-friendly area
that incorporates two large car parks
because those things seem to be in
Conflict so you're quite right to assume
earlier on you said
you look forward to the scoping that
goes on after the next elections and I
guess I'll be part of that we think
potentially have no issue with the
quality of what's been done I think it's
great but there is some issues to be
resolved there from certainly from my
end and it's not cheap Politics on
behalf no no like I understand
um I appreciate your comments I I think
as we said when we presented stage two
and again there's time for this in the
future as
part of the pride for my point of view
is civic pride which includes creating a
Civic Precinct
yeah
and if there's one part of the town that
should be important it should be the
home of the council
so how you link that
and there's probably more than one way
but I think that that's that's the
thought I would leave with you is
tie the people to the city tie the city
to the people and if you can do that and
you can find a way through whatever
Innovation is required maybe there's a
little bit of compromise but again don't
compromise the quality
so the quick response to that John
um that Assumption of tying the city to
the council assumes that the council
stays here
so my view of that is going forward is
we don't even know what's happening to
Council in the next three years
May well be Amalgamated that's on the
horizon sure our future may not be in
this building
could be somewhere else
yep that's for you but um thanks I don't
plan to look around corners
um I just look at what straight ahead
and work with what we know but you know
I take it on board
yes let's go
thank you Mr chair
can I just clarify what you're really
saying I think but I want to understand
clearly because it has some implications
for us
is that
to in order to make
the next stage
Mary harmoniously with the first stage
that we would really need to have the
same design as the same contract as I I
want to clarify because it does set the
income and conflict with our
um purchasing policies and strategies
and we need to understand that I I
totally get what you're saying and I and
I applaud that the fact that you as a
group have raised that with us because I
think it is important
um The Narrative the stories that the
streets are telling and the way they
Interlink with each other and
make a harmonious relationship between
the different parts of the inner city I
think is absolutely vital and I agree
with what you're saying but as as the
governors what we have to think about is
our other legal liabilities which may
slightly be in conflict with that and I
don't really understand but is that what
you your attention I think I'm I'm very
clear of mine that um
continuity of the intellectual property
embedded in people
not just on paper it's absolutely
critical I think
you know I appreciate you'll have
procurement policies the rest of it but
I also think you have a very experienced
professional team on staff who can make
sure that that does not compromise
both the um the value
and the competitiveness
of the way they're structured
I believe that they will they will more
than fulfill that responsibility I
appreciate the clarity of your answer
and the takefulness with which you
delivered it thank you um and but also
to thank your group for for
making us address theater show out loud
because it is important
John look I have seen the details for
stage two you know the concept drawings
but can you refresh me on the detail it
goes down to for stage two on how much
we've you've probably seen something
more recent and I've seen to be honest
because these guys have been working on
developing that detail doing the
costings and getting more detail done
and allows to
um I guess share it too widely until
they've um
from the develop points that everyone's
made is that from the design point of
view
as well you know it's underway but the
other contractors who do the digging and
Paving and I don't think no no no no no
no but we're able to raise develop point
when that goes out to Tinder you can see
the continuity of the designer if
they've sort of been asked to do that
next stage two yeah
um
perhaps Russell Russell could just give
you a pricey quickly of the status of
the design
Mr Michael might be as good but I'll
probably start with this one
I'm just going out the back line
we asked all at a concept stage and I
guess that's where the project
management officer is still working
through that that process to work with
and have discussions with the current
team about where that will go so we've
still got quite a lot of
um work to be done on that stage and I
guess part of that is that
what was prepared was a concept design
predominantly based around I guess that
handwriting of the first stage so we
could understand where that would be so
that we could consult
um which was done through the annual
plan
so there's still lots to do in that
space but there's no um
firmed view of how we will deliver that
formally Years yet
okay you don't want to say anything okay
like any more uh questions around
um
what John has raised
no
well the recommendation is that uh or
any other parts of the activities report
no so the recommendation is the
structural Services committee receives
the report activities report can I have
someone move that thank you Nigel
seconded councilor sopa I'm going to put
the motion all those in favor
aye against us
I just had some issues that I was
leaving till after John had done his
presentation sorry regarding the
activities report correct oh yeah sorry
no I will just yeah sorry I asked for
this a couple of messages I've had
feedback on the speed so John if you
want to go yeah thank you for your time
and for the questions appreciate it
thank you okay sorry sorry cancel the
clock
just on the speed
review signage which is uh Russell's
area
um had a bit of feedback from the Maui
and from Green Hills to about
the installation of Science and I just
wanted some clarification about did we
actually get it right like both those
small villagers have said that they've
got 100 speed limits running through
their Villages which was they thought
too much
so Mr chair
we adopted
um a new speed approach of which
um
the the intention is that we will bring
in our new speed limits on the um
3rd of October so to actually be able to
do that on a specific day we have been
out there and we've put signs up
and as part of our strategy we actually
effectively have on that day have to go
around and change all the signs from
what the current speed is to what the
new speed is so we've got a strategy
how we can deliver that on the day so
part of that is we've actually gone and
put the sign up and we've now posted the
speed that it's currently at so
and there have been a few places and
they are relatively small but
fortunately those those areas have
brought it to our attention and had
we've had quite active discussions with
those people in America is one of those
we're
we've got a sign and a good example
would be is it's right by the
um by the camp and it says the speed
signs is 100ks now that doesn't make any
sense at all
but the current legal speed limit in
that place is 100 K's its future speed
is 40k So within two weeks that um with
their magic wand on the um Sunday night
we will suddenly transfer all those
numbers to the new numbers and all those
problems will be fixed and we've put out
something like 400 signs in places
because that's legally what we need to
do to do that and there has been a
limited but a few and you know it's
great it's great that the people have
actually rung us and said to us I even
got this writer and that conversation
has occurred because they their
communities are recognizing what it was
and when you talk to them about what it
will be
they say yep that might not even be slow
enough yet and my answer to them is
let's just try it and then come back in
the next review because that's the
opportunity so we're actually seeing
some of the I guess the take-up of what
perhaps the consultation didn't
necessarily get out to be what's there
it's visual
um so there's a little bit of static out
there but I actually see it as a really
positive indicator that the people are
starting to absorb it and in early
October will mysteriously change all
those numbers overnight stopping
[Music]
um it cheers uh making a couple of weeks
ago chief executive raised the issue
about the pump station that runs on the
right hand side as you're going
um and there was some suggestion that
the road to odatara would be closed
again while that work went on so I got
some clarification from horror who's the
chairman of environment Southland he
said that work is not going to be done
for at least 12 months and maybe longer
but there will be some road closures
project has been delayed because of the
requirement to get some fish control
mechanisms that allow fish to go
backwards and forwards through the pump
station and that's been extremely
difficult and he also needs to consult
with the wider Community because the
project cost has gone from 3 to 12
million approximately so I just wanted
to clarify that because there was some
concern that we were sort of seen to be
closing the road to fix it and then five
minutes later we're closing out again to
do the pump station but pump station's a
separate project and has been delayed
beyond their control
generally done at the same time it
should have been done but they they
couldn't get the fish control mechanism
that was what he told me I had to get
made but anyway
right well good Council park now thank
you yep so we've had a for the
activities reported murder on the
secondary I put the motion all those in
favor
aye against that is carried
right that takes us back to um
there we go path management policy and
the guidelines
and
Russell you I used to live
thanks Mr chair the the functional
purpose of what this paper is is to
actually
bring I guess to the community how we
see the footpaths should be managed and
I guess through the public forum today
we've heard
um quite strongly
um from the disability sector how they
want to see the footpath be managed such
that they can have a barrier free access
to our city
one of the things that we've had over a
period of time within our bylaw actually
says that you're not allowed to do
anything in the Road Corridor without
the routing manager's approval
that in itself gives me a relative
degree on the appearance of actually to
do whatever is whatever that is and I
guess this policy this policy and
guideline looks to actually introduce
some documentation to give the community
a better steer and a bit of guidelines
to actually to know how that operates
and and that is really around how we
will actually I guess prioritize access
first and then use the footpath
thereafter and and the idea with this is
that the guidelines are there but we
also want to revisit the policy in a
relatively short time so that once we've
worked through with those businesses
that don't necessarily meet it at the
moment we can actually build a
transition plan
the community as a whole can give some
feedback and we can bring the policy and
guidelines back
I think we heard quite a
number of uh elements of feedback in the
public forum about the levels of
consultation and how we've gone about it
so we've done some pre-engagement so we
went out there to talk to some of the
groups this isn't a bylaw so and here
Rhiannon might want to talk about our
consultation approach to this or our
engagement approach but the idea the
idea has been that so we actually have
gone out there and started to talk to
some of those sector groups so that we
have a reasonable a reasonable idea of
the type of feedback that we'll have and
to be fair some are very supportive and
some are saying well this isn't going to
work for us at tables in the wrong place
but that's part of I guess part of what
this guidelines actually sets and you'll
have heard today
um from the speakers in the public forum
about the sorts of things that they see
as the issue that don't necessarily
always align with what everybody else
wants to do on the footpath so this
gives some robust guidelines for us to
work forward or
the community and we also had
opportunities how that some of those
things could be modified or barriers and
or
things that we can actually work through
so Rhiannon might want to comment on how
we've gone about that pre-engagement
um yes just to note that Council
supports the combined disability Network
which includes organizations like CCS
that you heard from today as well as a
range of individuals
um and the conversations took place with
that group as part of the pre-engagement
as well as with other organizations
directly affected like retailers and
Hospitality Outlets who be affected by
this potential policy so I think that
um those conversations have been really
helpful in terms of shaping the policy
and also having heard from some of those
people today in public forum shows the
opportunity that those people have
appreciated in terms of bringing their
views forward
okay
all good paper to answer any questions
right questions counselors
um Miss Cook and then councilor Clapp
so through to Russell through you Mr
chair how many
current Cafe on the street licenses are
you
current
active licenses we have a number of
people who are using the footpath and
most don't have a current license
right so we've got some work to do with
those people and the past there's been
many that have but over the last while
we haven't necessarily had licensed of
those areas doesn't mean to say we don't
have conversations with them but they're
not necessarily licensed
so as a result of today and the
consultation that you've been doing
going forward as part of the requirement
going to be things like the
um
some sort of barrier between the cafe
space and the public walking access
space as indicated particularly with the
um
[Music]
um
low-sighted community and that sort of
thing in terms of the use of canes as
opposed to everything else the the
requirement that they have to need some
sort of fixed guide as to how they
navigate the footpath so someone who
wishes to have going forward have a um
use the footpath will need to meet we'll
we'll need to follow the guidelines and
meet our policy and
why I would anticipate where it's
um whether some I guess difference then
the ideal thing would be to have a
conversation with both the parties to
see if there's actually a solution here
because part of it we don't necessarily
want to stop the vibrancy of any of
those businesses because that's what
we're looking for at city center but at
the same time we don't want to create
barriers for people who can't use our
city center so we'll just need to
continue to work through that and I
think once people get to understand how
the guidelines work
and that the policy is trying to I guess
solve some of those problems by by
making it clear what everybody expects
then they won't necessarily bring things
to us that they know won't actually
follow that so the answer to all those
questions are there's some lots of
places we have to go and have hard
conversations with and we've already
Leslie's been out there and talked to
started that conversation with those and
um that will be that that transition and
as new um I guess businesses open all
those things occur then we'll need to
just work through those and actually
make sure that we get I guess a more
positive approach going forward
um it's not I don't anticipate we want
to go out there and throw everybody off
the street it's going to be we want to
work with everybody to see if we can
keep our city as vibrant because that's
what we're been investing in and we just
need to make sure that we can deliver
that
thank you okay Council Clark then
councilor Adler yeah thank you um
Russell just in relation to wakner place
does this policy apply to just the
footpath that goes around the very edge
on D or given the people crisscross
through it going to
Lower East Street yes I saw the look on
your face here
um and I mean I like the policy I think
it gives a lot of flexibility for both
parties both those that want to access
and those that want to increase the
vibrancy but if if we're looking in the
future to
improving the I guess the ability of
walking a place to add the vitamin C as
John Green just recently said
um would this place some restraints
around that
I'll start and let Leslie finishing this
one um what new place is a reasonably
interesting place because it's formed as
part of its reserve and part of its road
so I guess we have to look at how those
both those policies so um
through you Mr chair
um So the plan for walkner places on the
D Street edge of it that it will be a
three meter clearance space for
pedestrians and along the edges of the
buildings in through wakner place it
will be 2.5 meters of clearance for the
buildings but as we say with the master
planning Etc moving forward and a short
policy time frame a review that can all
be changed
feathered it Mr chair we've seen that
we've actually had a coffee business
situated in their
during this construction and
demonstrated that perhaps it might be
some option so I guess in the past that
probably was things that we wouldn't
have considered
what in a place to be useful for and I
guess it shows that it's part of our
learning as a city as we're developing
that we can survive in those spaces and
it works so I think it highlights that
that actually gives us some further
thinking that we might need to do in
those spaces thank you thank you
Council hello thanks Jim I guess one of
the things that this does is it pulls
together several other policies that I
was a part of in the past and it was
always the argument over we have signage
and some difficulty with it being up
against the edge of the footpath
um but also around charging people for
what essentially is an extension of
space for their business and we did have
an initial stage about half a dozen
um coffee shops around town that that
had that and were charged and that as
Russell said was something that fell by
the wayside but
there shouldn't be any fear of
someone who's running a temporary
business having to pay for that space
because it doesn't accept counseling
record earlier I mentioned e-bikes if
e-bikes want to set up somewhere they've
got to take leasing that space into part
of their operational costs
um and I really have no issue with that
particularly from you know that it it's
going to be mostly Hospital
that's affected I don't know about
fences I think they can be just as much
a trip Hazard but having some sort of
clear delineation between where those
dining areas are we have seen opposite
my office on on D Street a real blur
between a couple of um businesses there
that at some stages have taken up
virtually the entire footpath or in some
cases it's the clients that have gone
and shifted the furniture around
I guess much as I love rules I want to
make sure that we still allow the
flexibility that we do at that special
time of year when we Rumble with the
sound of motorcycles
and we allow them to park up on
footpaths and it does become
a bit of a hazard and a difficult time
of
pedestrian negotiation but it is only
only for that week
um
and and I think if we're able to take
that into account we're we're on the
road for something that creates
[Music]
um
some control around the the vibrancy
that we've invested Millions into
so Mr Mr chair part of that is that we
have um in our ongoing challenges to
continue to keep
um the low vision uh part of the
community well informed what's happening
just not in our city center but
everywhere across season every traffic
management plan we
um are able to need to be able to
convince or convey the information about
where it is and I think part of part of
the use in those sort of event or
activation periods is actually how we
continue to engage with that group and
how we can continue to inform them and
keep them up to date with it
thank you okay further questions or
comments
we've got four recommendations here to
receive the report note the feedback
from the pre-engagement and approve the
policy
um
no the policy review date
so ongoing feedback can be considered
and worked through and prove the
guidelines the footpath guidelines and
approve that the current fees and
charges
the adult Cafe seating be applied to all
licenses and know that there is no
current fee applicable for signage
boards and the review of any and all
fees will be aligned to Future annual
plans so if everyone's happy to move
those as a group of six can I have
someone move that please Council Lewis
seconded Council Ludlow I'll put the
motion all those in favor
aye aye yes that is Kerry thank you very
much for that Russell Leslie
thank you
now Alistair
welcome you for the update on the search
for the Emergency water supply it sounds
like the title of the movie yeah
Sean Connery
thank you Mr chair uh the intent of this
report is just to update counselors on
we were at the fair investigation
um last report was as you said in April
sometimes I left since then
um in that report we
outlined the grief we had in doing the
first pumping test was the failure of
monitoring equipment we've since
installed permanent monitoring equipment
much higher level of technology and able
to
um repeat the pumping test
also dispel a fear that we had couldn't
answer last time that was that the the
water bearing strata that we're
interested in the chatting formation
200 meters below ground level is
actually overlaid by other water bearing
strata notably the collectively they're
called the gore lignite measures and
they were the measures we used to draw
water from prior to 1960.
um they are very poor the upper levels
are very poor quality and we were
concerned that there might be leakage
from the upper levels down at the
chattan formation which would um
contaminate the good water quality that
we've been able to detect so far so I'm
pleased to report that the second pump
test
showed that there wasn't sufficient
leakage to undermine the quality of
water
in the chain formation so that's a good
outcome
we need to do more testing though
and unfortunately there is no dedicated
budget for that testing
in this report I've said that we'll come
back to council as soon as we've got the
details of both where our expenditure
lies and our various parts of council to
see if we can accommodate a budget and
also how much that budget may be
so at that point Mr chair I'll um
be happy to ask any questions counselors
may have thanks for that so that's good
news about that contamination between
the two layers right uh Council Clark
serious questions
um Alistair and
in relation to the contamination issue
um
is that impacted by the recent um
drought that we've had we had a newer
scientist uh a couple of months ago gave
us some impact about
um the drought that we had in Southland
and they and they said well we've now
got some rain and the rivers are flowing
okay it will take five to eight years
for the Aquas around Southland to
recover so it's not an instant rain and
everything's fine Dandy and I just
wondered if there is some recovery from
that
will that impact onto your testing what
will there be some potential to to
contaminate if there's greater water
levels in that
that you refer to
I don't believe so okay but
um
I keep repeating this when you're
looking for anything underground whether
it be gold oil or water you are in
effect prospecting sure and we don't
know much about this chat information at
all in fact the only real information we
have of it is what we've discovered
during the course of our investigations
we put two balls down
and we're looking and investing
something of the order of just under 20
million and 25 26 so we really want to
get this right before we commit wholly
to it but it's looking very promising at
the moment we just need more information
and I think the consenting Authority we
do need to get a consent draw water from
this considering Authority being
environment cells and will require more
information to be supplied or accompany
any resource consent to draw water from
it okay and the other question which
you've sort of raised in in your paper
is the issue of um are we looking for
this water supply to be an emergency
water supply or is it something that we
have more online as a source of incoming
work and I just wonder what your view
was on that because it seems to me
there's a some ways a bit of a penny
both ways if we do the emergency stuff
it might be a cheaper option than trying
to look for it as a source of ongoing
Supply but having said that looking
forward to what we know is coming like
the hydrogen plant that and the salmon
hatchery at Bluff which will both
require fresh water is it something that
we want to develop in a more formal way
than just having it as an emergency
supply
I think the further testing we do should
give us a insight as to whether or not
the resources capable of being used on
an everyday basis which I think you were
suggesting rather than initially the
exercise was set up to create resilience
in the water supply network we we're
solely dependent on one source of water
and so the concept then was just to look
for a supply to help us out in times of
difficulty since then perhaps buoyed by
the initial results we've seen from this
the idea has been floated to all perhaps
we can use this resource for something
more than just an emergency supply okay
thank you foreign
if this becomes a successful water
source for us would it require storage
there or would it go to brank's home and
could we use the existing Bluff water
line are there any synergies there or
you need to create the whole
infrastructure take it and then be
treated have you got that far down how
it could work yes I I think
it would need new infrastructure to
convey water not to break some my
mindset is to um take it back to our
Reservoir storage in the city here and
distribute it from there to do that we
would need a separate pipeline from the
blood pipeline to do that to give you an
idea of the bluff pipeline is normally
about 300 millimeter in diameter the
brakes on pipelines there's more than
one a 600. so if we're going to use a
significant what I'm trying to say is a
significant volume of water not more
than what we Supply Bluff and sbm we
need a much bigger pipe than the blood
pipeline currently is
so we would look to create a connecting
pipe from the bore field and treatment
plant because it will be treated on site
at our Rua yeah back into our system
probably at our main reservoir pump
station locations okay thank you
Miss Scott
not wanting to ask you to go into any
particular sensitive information but in
terms of the search and the
um geology of the site how happy are you
that extraction on a long-term basis
from that particular aquifer may not
collapse at a future date in other words
how much is the how much is the depth
between
where you're taking the water from and
what's overhead and what is that
comprised of how much of it is
substantial and how much of it is that
course
thing that you're worried about what's
the what's the depth between the two
um
I can't recall exactly I mentioned to
you the formation that we wanted to draw
from is normally about 220 meters below
ground level and I think the next
level up might be about 150 so you're
talking about 50 70 meters
um but when you're drawing water long
term day in day out there is a
them we're probably going to have to
assess whether there's um potential for
settlement
um we have to accompany any resource
consent with a thing called an AE an
assessment of environmental effects so
we have to look at all these sorts of
issues and the consenting Authority will
will require us to do so
um not only from the point of um
the welfare of the resource we're
drawing from but the whole impact on the
whole environment
I only ask because I'm mindful that some
of the aquifers that were used in
Canterbury that everybody thought were
inexhaustible
um
started to collapse
in certain places well there's all sorts
of threats at the same aren't you know
it's close to the coastline uh salt
water intrusion that kind of all those
things have to be
an attempt to evaluate the risk and we
just don't have enough information to do
all that just yet I appreciate your
answers
right
any further questions Council Clark just
one click on elster um which I think
Mark has sort of alluded to
um
the pipeline that goes to Bluff at the
moment it meets bluff's needs but if we
have further needs for fresh water there
be it hydrogen albeit the Hatchery for
the salmon Farms
um is that going to require more
capacity like does the pipe
have enough Grunt in it to do that or
are we gonna have to throw another
pipeline down
it doesn't have significant
um Surplus capacity most of it's taken
up by the milk and um
meat processing plant at our SPM so
there isn't a lot of fat left in that
pipeline to send down to blood thank you
all right for the questions
no okay thank you very much Alistair
um the recommendations are we received
the report on the updates on the search
for the water supply
thank you moved Council seven second
Miss cook for the motion all those in
favor
aye
yes that is carried that moves us on now
to
heading further south to Bluff
and it's the
stopping road stopping a disposal of
stop Road Lagan Street
thanks Mr chair this is part of the
process that was commenced some while
ago in December and it is the actual
formal element of a piece of road that
has been
consulted on with the community to go
through the local government acts
requirements to actually say let's stop
this road and then should it be agreed
to be stopped then it can be disposed of
and currently it is proposed that we
when the recommendations that we give
the approval to the chief executive to
negotiate that disposal
um during through this process we
followed the ACT which includes advising
the adjacent neighbors publicly
advertising the paper and putting signs
up and we received no feedback we also
have we also have approached the walking
and access commission which is a
statutory group that actually protects
access to the uh against the coastline
and they had no objection to this so
um the recommendations are
what council that this proceed okay
thank you uh questions for
Council clerk
um you know I think all councils
received
um an email from Rodney in the last
couple days that raised some issues so I
guess
I'm happy to raise those and
maybe get some uh discussion going
around it
um
he's raised the issue of the uh of the
bluff one yeah
additional piece of land
it's over an old Bluff landfill right on
the edge of an Old Quarry and he worries
about the safety of it so it's the first
issue
and who would Council be liable if we
sold off the land and there was
subsequently some issues there and the
second the issue that he States is that
on the meeting of the 7th of December
I'm unaware of this that we gave it on
taking that parcel of land will go to
the marketplace and not be just offered
to the adjoining um property owners so
whether you can help me with either
those two would be great
so Mr chair I guess there's two elements
so that's the first one is you can stop
the road and then and then you can
actually decide what you want to do with
it it becomes a pass when you then
decide what you want to do with it
um I know that our league our team the
guys and her team have have looked at
those and we don't believe that we have
any
um I guess issues with the adjacent
property
um the if it sold to somebody then they
uh buyer beware okay
and the I guess in terms of the sale
the legislation actually allows for that
for for the road that stopped to be to
be sold to an adjacent property
I guess that's the process
um
I think part of that will actually be
sure that the the process of disposal
um meets a fear a fair price and um we
have seen an offer but that's I guess a
part of this is actually saying is what
do we how do we establish what a fair
price for this piece of land is
okay
um we're gonna have Marcus yeah look I
just I'm not entirely sure how to do
this I think probably I'd like to
declare a conflict of interest in this I
think it's a piece of land that I have
had an offer on and has had some
involvement with so I think probably
it's best if I
to clear that and remove myself from the
discussions if that's appropriate no
that's fine thank you for notifying that
yes everyone
um Mr
Mr chantage
it appears that elected members have
received a pace of communication that
has not been shared with me I find it
very challenging when we are sitting in
a public meeting discussing a matter
like this that I am not privy to
whatever the concerns are and I just
want to draw that to the attention of
everybody at the table I do recognize
that there are people who feel
challenged by the fact that monofin were
us sitting at this table however that is
a decision that this table made
we are privy to most things that
everybody else is and I think when it
pertains to something that we are
expected to make a decision on at this
meeting tonight that I should have been
privy to it as should have Miss coat and
I want to actually informed the chair
and the rest of the members that I am
extremely unhappy about that I think it
is disrespectful
um I guess uh my take on it is that the
email was sent by a member of the public
to councilors now
I'm not sure about the sharing of that
email uh where we sit
um of that
um it would be up to the person I know
I've received emails that have been sent
to me and maybe two other counselors
I don't pass that on to everyone I
understand where you're coming from here
and councilor Clark has raised an issue
regarding
things that were raised about the land
formation the actual overlap onto the
Quarry and the tip and so he's brought
that to council there was no other
information that I can recall that it
was just about raising exactly what
councilor Clark's done so
um I'm not sure about the Privacy Act of
sharing emails
what we do if we receive one
pass it on I'm not 100 sure it was sent
by a member of the public it wasn't a
formal counselor
excuse me it's simple lobbying
um
and it's up to councils to do what with
as they can and as you say that the
relevant point was raised by councilor
Clark as a as a question I don't think
you've missed anything but I do take the
point um that maybe they uh submit a
Lobby a uh should probably bear in mind
in future
yes Michael
um just speaking on behalf of the
council relation to that any
communication that does come via C's
office does get communicated to all
Council and manafino erupts this is an
example of one that did not go through
that channel
so the point then remains Mr chair how
much Credence we can give to that given
that both the monofino Reps have deep
links into the community and could have
researched the background to these
particular remarks about the you know
landfill etc etc I think
in order for us all to make it effective
decisions we need to be sharing common
information I appreciate the councilor
Clark mentioned it or I would have not
known of its existence however the point
is if there are real concerns how do we
address them
given that the people who could have
found out some of the answers without
too much effort didn't even know of the
existence of the query
um well
if Counselor Clark hadn't spoken this
would have gone silent
and nothing would have been known but
I'll let counselor can't speak you had
your hand up
um two issues I guess through your chair
um
Russell how important is it that we make
a decision on this today
Mr T this is the price you set start in
December and obviously the process was
initiated by the adjacent property owner
with an interest
um it's taken us a period of time to get
there it could it could rest I guess the
process of us Consulting and out into
the public during that formal period
which the legislation requires us to do
uh receive we receive no public feedback
during that period so okay
um
equally and respectfully you could
stop the road yeah and then actually
hold over the disposal or
or seek further information on the
disposal there's two steps in here the
first one is
um stop it being Road and then you can
decide what you want to do with it
you don't have to necessarily dispose of
it
and that would certainly be my
recommendation given what Evelyn said I
think we should have an input into this
given the location of the site was not
my intention to bypass that anything it
was just given to me and I gave an
undertaking to Rodney that I would raise
it
um means of lobbying in this case a
piece of lobbying when there had been
public notification which had actually
allowed for
a process to be followed that
unfortunately for whatever reason the
lobbyists
that can take that Advantage take
advantage of that